bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement rouge accueille
cette fois elodie chabrol qui est
doctorant sur en neurosciences
fondatrice de kind of serious france est
maintenant directrice internationale de
paint of sound si je me trompe pas
bonjour et le dit bonjour les tout à
fait tu t'es pas trompé du tout souffert
parce que les rares fois où je me suis
trompé sur un truc ça allait pas bien
choisi me donner à fond
bref est ce que tu peux présenter un
petit peu ton parcours pas de problème
alors mon parcours en fait donc
effectivement j'ai fait une thèse en
neurosciences à paris sur l'épilepsie et
je suis parti après hop aux docks à
londres faire un premier post doc la
jeune avait un petit peu moins de
travailler sur l'épilepsie je voulais
voir autre chose donc je suis parti
travailler sur le nerf sciatique donc
toujours de la neuro mais là c'est sur
le nerf qui est généralement fait mal en
haut des jambes là juste au dessus de la
fesse et puis basse l'épilepsie le
cerveau m'a manqué donc je suis retourné
faire un deuxième colloque sur
l'épilepsie sa part des banques
et ouais non mais tu sais c'est enfin
voilà j'avais c'était hyper fascinant
comme boulot et c'est vrai que passer
passer du cerveau aux nerfs en fait le
nerf c'est juste c'est comme si tu
passais d'une carte mère d'un ordi un
fil électrique quoi beaucoup trop simple
exactement
ouais c'était voilà ça m'intéressait pas
trop ça me manquait vraiment de
de challenge et du coup je suis retourné
retourner sur l'épilepsie et j'ai fait
un deuxième post doc qui a duré quatre
ans et demi et pendant ce temps là en
fait je suis tombé sur paint of times au
tout début où ça secret et du coup j'ai
joint pines haynes donc en angleterre au
tout début j'ai participé à la création
du de la première édition
et puis effectivement samassa m'a
énormément plu et donc je leur ai
proposé de de faire en sorte que le
festival soit internationale c'est un
peu à cause de moi si c'est partout dans
tous les pays maintenant
parce que vraiment j'avais j'avais envie
que ça se restreignent pas juste à
l'angleterre quoi et voilà et je les
jeux les embarquer en france et
maintenant j'aide les nouveaux pays a à
le mettre en place chez eux quoi c'est
ok je reviens pas en arrière quand
comment on en est arrivé à t'intéresser
aux neurosciences quelques est ce que tu
as fait déjà inventé est ok donc
pourquoi les neurosciences alors
j'aurais bien aimé en fait dire que les
neurosciences sais pas ce que j'ai
entendu un neuroscientifique parler et
que sama samaja bailly ou
ou une réponse super folle de dire j'ai
lu un livre j'ai vu une découverte mais
en fait je détestais ça à la fac mais
vraiment je détestais je voulais
absolument pas faire ça j'étais
généticienne au début et j'ai fait mon
stage de m1 en génétique donc pas du
tout en neurosciences et quand j'ai
demandé à mon encadrante à l'époque ce
qu'elles avaient commis des ou comme
contact avec qui je pouvais faire une
thèse elle m'a dit bah tiens la pitié
salpêtrière je connais bien une équipe
qui travaille en euros génétique etc
et au final je me suis embarqué
là-dedans et j'ai fini par faire de la
neuro alors qu'au départ c'est vraiment
ce que je voulais pas faire et puis au
final je suis tombé complètement
amoureuse en commençant ma thèse quoi
enfin en tout cas mon m2 sur la neuro
donc je suis tombé dedans complètement
par hasard bon m2 que vaut pas
complètement par hasard non pas par
hasard mais c'était de la génétique je
voulais vraiment faire de la génétique
humaine pas nécessairement des
neurosciences était voilà vraiment la
génétique humaine et on m'a proposé ça
et c'est vrai que quand j'ai vu le
projet quand j'ai vu quand j'ai vu
l'impact que ça pouvait avoir j'avais
envie vraiment de travailler en
recherche donc en m1 m2 etc
j'ai toujours travaillé sur des
pathologies ou en tout cas de la
recherche plus ou moins appliquée quand
même j'avais besoin toujours d'avoir un
moteur un peu de me dire ce que je fais
peut potentiellement changer la vie des
gens quoi ok mais du coup cette envie de
faire de la recherche séné en m1 ou
serra vont à wayss & néant et main alors
c'est assez marrant parce que quand
j'étais plus jeune je voulais être prof
donc prof prof au lycée ou au collège et
du coup en faisant de la bio à la fac on
m'a dit non mais l'agrégation c'est trop
compliqué c'est vraiment un concours
assez difficile vaut mieux que tu fasses
une thèse ce sera plus facile alors la
personne qui a dit ça clairement de ça
mais pas de quoi elle parlait et surtout
qu'elle a dit ouais c'est un concours
l'agrégation l'attestent sera plus
facile
alors madame y avait quand même un
concours au départ pour avoir une bourse
donc c'était un conseil tout pourri
jeune étudiante je te conseillerais tu
avoir un prix nobel en médecine si
possible cette idée beau et facile
après tu te seras tu passes il postera
prix nobel voilà exactement et donc du
coup bah moi je les écoute et je suis
dit ok j'ai faire une thèse et j'ai
continué en master de recherche et m1 m2
et c'est vrai qu'en master bas
franchement je suis tombé complètement
amoureuse et ce qui est dommage et c'est
vrai que j'essaie de changer ça avec la
communication scientifique c'est que
c'est un métier pour le coup que je ne
connaissais pas du tout avant mon master
on en croise peu des chercheurs on n'a
pas forcément les régions d'en
rencontrer maintenant oui mais à
l'époque il ya quinze ans on n'avait pas
forcément la possibilité de rencontrer
autant de chercheurs et chercheuses que
maintenant et on savait pas forcément ce
que c'était que le métier de chercheur
donc forcément dans ta tête tu
t'imagines pas faim moi en tout cas je
m'imaginais pas être chercheuse parce
que voilà ce n'était pas quelque chose
que je connais c'est quoi ok et qu'est
ce qui t'a plu du coup dans la recherche
bas tout en fait les manips j'ai adoré
ça
je pense que j'ai fait comme j'ai fait
toujours de la recherche appliquée
travailler sur des maladies réfléchir et
me dire potentiellement là on accumule
du savoir qui va aider les gens tu vois
le fait de vraiment travailler sur
quelque chose d' appliquer et puis voilà
de lire des cas et de se dire il ya des
gens qu'on cette maladie là et là ce que
je suis en train de faire c'est utile je
pense que vraiment je me sentis
l'utilité que ça avait derrière et j'ai
bien aimé puis deux puis il ya un truc
depuis que je suis toute petite je pose
des questions tout le temps je demande
tout le temps pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
et j'aime bien comprendre et je pense
que lâche la recherche pour le coup
c'était vraiment parfait pour moi quoi
ça me permettait de poser tout le temps
des questions de pourquoi ça et pourquoi
et comment ça marche et de comprendre
comment ça marche quoi et du mouton
sujet de recherche de thèse du coup
c'était l'épilepsie
c'était quoi en particulier alors
c'était un type d'épilepsie que je
trouve assez assez fascinant donc
l'épilepsie yahia pas juste un type de
maladie on a vraiment des tonnes il ya
plein plein de types différents et le
celui sur lequel je travaillais moi
c'était ça s'exprimer de deux façons
soit les patients avaient des crises
d'épilepsie qui étaient déclenchées par
des son style une sonnerie de téléphone
ou une voix auquel il s'attendait pas
qu'ils les appels d'une autre pièce etc
soit les crises en elle-même était
d'aider aura auditifs donc des
hallucinations auditives et notamment il
ya une des équipes qui travaillent sur
cette forme d'épilepsie qui a écrit tout
un article en disant que jeanne d'arc
était probablement épileptiques
donc c'est assez génial ce qu'ils ont
fait ils ont repris tous les procès de
jeanne d'arc
ah ouais non mais c'est cette étude je
la trouve géniale ils ont repris tous
les procès de jeanne d'arc ou ou là y
avait toutes les descriptions vraiment
hyper détaillés de de quels étaient ces
symptômes dans quels cas elle entendait
des voix
si c'était plutôt la nuit etc ils ont
repris tout ça ils ont analysé tout ça
ils ont dit mais en fait nous on pense
que jeanne d'arc elle est épileptique
elle n'est pas schizophrène ou folle ou
quoi elle est épileptique et il ya un
gène qui a impliqué notamment dans cette
forme d'épilepsie et et ils sont 10 bat
puisqu'à l'époque on signait tu sais on
sait l'est les lettres avec de la cire
et un cheveu donc ils sont partis à la
recherche des cheveux de jeanne d'arc
alors c'est un papier qui date de 2006
on est en 2013 2000 par 2019 ça fait ça
fait 13 ans qui sont partis à la
recherche de cheveux je ne sais pas
s'ils ont trouvé et qui sont pu faire
une analyse adn du mystère dit chez eux
heynckes exact heures et donc je
travaillais sur ce type d'épilepsie là
est ce que j'ai adoré pendant ma thèse
c'est qu'en fait j'ai commencé en
génétique donc vraiment le tout petit
après je suis allé voir donc
ce gène qui est impliqué dans des formes
d'épilepsie l'idée c'était d'essayer de
diagnostiquer certains patients j'avais
des patients car cette forme d'épilepsie
on a cherché chez eux s'ils y avait donc
des mutations dans ce gène qui serait
responsable de leur donne leur épilepsie
on a trouvé deux mutations différentes
nouvelles et du coup comme c'était un
mécanisme assez nouveau d'épilepsie on
est en fait ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on
ait appris des cellules on a mis les
protéine mutée donc dans ces cellules
pour essayer de voir comment est ce que
c'était comment est ce que les crises
d'épilepsie pouvait être causés donc
elle commence comportait c'est protéine
mutée comparé aux protéines normale et
et après j'ai eu la chance en trois ans
quand même de combiner ça avec un modèle
de souris qu'on a lancé au tout début de
ma thèse est que j'ai réussi à avoir à
la toute fin de ma thèse en trois ans ou
là du coup on a on a pu un petit peut
avoir un petit peu plus d'idées sur
comment ça se passe comment se passe
l'épilepsie et c est ce qui est dur en
euros c'est que on est souvent que j'ai
travaillé avec des animaux parce qu'on a
besoin d'un cerveau entier pour avoir
toutes les interactions de tous les
neurones voire même un organisme pour
avoir le cerveau qui interagit avec
l'organisme et ça malheureusement on n'a
pas encore trouvé de de remplacement à
ça donc voilà mais c'était c'était une
thèse bien complète donc ok je vous ai
modifié laisser les neurones de la
troïka et du coup il avait utilisé son
web le changement de l'évacuation de
ronald de la souris comme ça
alors en fait ce qu'on a fait c'était
donc l'épilepsie généralement scellier
en tout cas les piles et les formes
d'épilepsie génétique alors on va
recommencer l'épilepsie de base c'est en
gros un court-circuit il faut voir le
cerveau comme comme un gros circuits
électriques et l'épilepsie c'est qu'il
ya une surcharge un endroit donc il ya
un court circuit qui va se passer et les
différentes formes d'épilepsie ça varie
suivant le type de court-circuit donc
est ce que c'est un petit court circuit
dans un coin du cerveau ou là ça va être
une petite crise où est-ce que ça va
être tout le cerveau qui va court
circuiter d'un coup et là on va se
retrouver avec des crises de style celle
qu'on voit bien qu'on a en tête qu'on
voit souvent dans les dents les films
les gens qui tombent sur le côté qui se
mettent à bavay qui risquent de manger
leur langue etc qui convulse etc etc
et voilà les épilepsies à des formes
génétiques donc qu'ils sont qui sont
héréditaires con qu'on passe d'une
génération à l'autre et ça généralement
c'est dû à des mutations dans des dans
des canaux ioniques
donc en fait les neurones qui sont les
cellules du cerveau passent
l'information à l'intérieur de
électriquement mais en fait entre chaque
neurone ya un espace et donc pour passer
l'info il faut des petites des petites
molécules qui sont libérés et les
molécules elle passe par des petits
canaux ioniques donc c'est des petits
trous dans un dans un neurone qui passe
et qui va aller dans le neurone d'en
face et souvent ces canaux généralement
sont mutés donc ce qui se passe c'est
que soit il laisse passer trop dion et
comme lésions sont chargés ça va faire
trop d'électricité ou pas assez en fait
donc donc souvent c'est comme ça que
l'épée les petits arrivent c'est que
voilà il ya un trop plein d'électricité
qui est dû à ça en tout cas pour les
formes génétiques et là ma thèse elle
s'est portée sur une protéine sécrétée
donc en gros pour une normalement c'est
un cadeau donc un petit trou dans la
cellule dans le neurone qui laisse
passer des petites particules chargées
et là en fait c'était pour la première
fois un mécanisme complètement différent
c'est une protéine qui sortait du
neurone et qui allait se balader donc
généralement on pensait sur le neurone
d'à côté probablement mais qui pouvaient
interagir avec d'autres choses autour en
fait et
et ces terres mécanisme vraiment
complètement nouveau et hyper
intéressant à analyser parce qu'au final
c'était une forme d'épilepsie qu'on
connaissait pas du tout en tout cas
forme d'épilepsie génétique qu'on
connaissait pas du tout alors qu'un [ __ ]
que des questions parce que en fait en
machine learning et on a quelques
modèles comme ça on essaie d'avoir des
des circuits neuronaux pas deux neurones
artificiels on essaie d'avoir des
signaux qui serait trop dommage est un
des gros problèmes souvent c'est que
justement c'est très difficile de
contrôler le le flux d'informations il
peut y avoir des beaucoup ça explose
comme ça et du coup dans le temps de
cerveau il ya des mécanismes naturels
pour essayer de deux d'anticiper ces
surcharges électriques
alors en fait il ya plein de choses il
ya déjà dans le cerveau il n'y a pas que
les neurones il ya tout ce qui est
cellules gliales dont on parle pas
beaucoup au final
parce que généralement on pense aux
neurones qui sont les cellules
majoritaire et les cellules au final qui
sont utiles mais les noeuds les cellules
gliales typiquement c'est des cellules
de cd baby sitter donc elles sont là
pour nettoyer le trop-plein de
neurotransmetteurs par exemple donc les
neurotransmetteurs c'est comme je disais
tout à l'heure les neurones au milieu il
ya des trous faut que
l'info passe donc à l'intérieur de ces
de la chimie c'est de la physique pardon
de l'électricité et entre deux neurones
ça sera plutôt de la chimie donc ça va
être des molécules des
neurotransmetteurs des molécules charges
etc
donc tu as les cellules gliales qui vont
nettoyer qui vont faire en sorte qu'il
n'y ait pas de résidus qu'une fois que
le message est passé
s'il y avait beaucoup de
neurotransmetteurs ça va pas traîner là
est resté et risquer de pourrir un peu
l'atmosphère autour
et puis et puis en termes de neurones
tata différents neurones les neurones
excitateur et les neurones inhibiteur et
du coup ça il ya des neurones qui vont
être là juste pour vraiment leur boulot
quand ils vont être activés ça va être
d'inhiber les voit donc de dire oh là on
se calme et du coup c'est vrai que
comparé du coup en fait ça fait une
boucle de plein de choses y aller c'est
le béal qui sont là qui nettoie les
neurones qui activent ceux qui ceux qui
sont là pour calmer le jeu et c est
et au final du coup je pense que c'est
hyper compliqué de résumer ça en machine
où tu vas en électricité etc
et c'est le gros challenge qui met du
coup en de quoi en injectant cc
protéines goût tu peux quand même
réguler anticipé de lg y avait lieu en
tout cas la mienne soit lui non joy en
août potentiellement du coup ça se prend
vous pourriez les utiliser pour essayer
de les injecter vacances à saint jacques
déjà ça directement le cerveau en fait
alors pas forcément parce que quand
injectent des protéines dans le cerveau
souvent la durée de vie à l'est pas elle
est pas énorme
ça peut peut-être maximum durer 24
heures quelque chose comme ça donc ce
qui vaut mieux faire et ça c'est ce que
j'ai fait en post doc c'est plutôt de la
thérapie génique
c'est à dire que tu tu te débrouilles
donc généralement tu mets un gène qui va
donc produire une protéine tu le mets
dans un virus le virus il a rien
dangereux parce qu'il va revoir tout qui
va être si tu veux tout ce qui est
dangereux qui va être enlevée par
exemple prendre quand on prend le virus
du hiv on enlève tout ce qui fait de lui
vraiment le hiv par contre on garde tout
ce qui va faire de lui un 30 un moyen de
transport hockey et on va garder le fait
qu'il infecte des cellules qui rentre
dedans qui qui met de l'adn dans des
cellules donc ça c'est ce qui fait en
tant que virus
par contre l'adn qui met d'habitude
c'est son adn de hiv et qui va faire une
maladie
nous on va remplacer sa part un adn
donc un gène qui va produire une
protéine qui va rétablir justement le
calme au niveau neuronale donc
l'électricité parfois quand les
thérapies géniques c'est quand on sait
qu'il ya un jeune qui était abîmée chez
des patients du coup là on met la
version la version nickel du gène dans
un virus et ça permet ça permet d'avoir
des cellules après qui produisent une
version normale du gène qui produisent
une version normale de la protège vous a
complètement fou tout servi c'est juste
génial ses fantasmes et du coup en fait
normalement donc ce virus va va aller
dans des vins infecter des cellules va
infecter des neurones normalement ce qui
fait c'est qu'il va poser son matériel
adn qui là qu'il a dans son petit
véhicule il va poser de l'adn dans des
cellules est en fait il ya deux types de
cellules ya les cellules qui se divisent
au moment enfin pendant la vie quoi et
donc là du coup il va hérésie avoir une
dilution de ce petit morceau d'adn qui
est posée là parce que il n'est pas
forcément intégré à l'adn parfois il est
juste poser s'il a intégré du coup quand
la cellule se divise elle garde l'adn et
du coup elle continuera les cellules
fille continuerons d'exprimer sa et du
coup voilà les cellules les cellules
exprime ce gène comme si c'était comme
si c'était leur propre génétique donc du
coup elle continue de l'exprimer tout au
long de la vie et si tout va bien aux
thérapies géniques teinte injecte une
fois et et le gène est exprimé tout le
long donc il n'y a plus besoin de réagir
dessus donc c'est vraiment génial bloqué
parce que du coup l'adn que tu essaies
d'injecter vers la thérapie génique
s'accroche directement à la bienvenue
oui alors il va aller s'intégrer dans
l'adn humain
dans ces cellules là est généralement
voilà il ya quand même beaucoup beaucoup
d'endroits de l'adn qui sont inutiles
entre guillemets ou en tout cas qui ne
cote pas pour des gènes activés donc
généralement ce qui est bien que la
thérapie génique c'est que on a de la
chance en termes de probabilité tu
pourrais nous expliquer beaucoup d'air
mais en termes de probables généralement
les jeunes vont se mettre dans des
endroits où c'est vide entre guy enfin
généralement vide
voilà et après effectivement ils sont
ils sont exprimés comme comme les gènes
de la cellule quoi ok ça fait combien de
temps qu'on fait un peu de haut -
laboratoire d'état thérapie génique
comme ça ça fait la date exacte je crois
que ses fins dès ses débuts des années
2000 donc ça doit faire une vingtaine
d'années quelque chose comme ça il
faudrait que je retrouve la date mais
elle est vraiment les idées de thérapie
génique ça fait ça fait assez longtemps
qu'on y pense en tout cas et qu'on
essaye il ya plein plein de type de
thérapie génique donc moi je te parle là
de deux mètres 1 gènes de virus mais la
thérapie génique super à la mode en ce
moment c'est chris par cris sparkasse
neuf ou là l'idée c'est carrément
d'introduire un outil qui va céder petit
ciseau génétique donc tu peux tu peux
faire en sorte qu'ils aillent à un
endroit précis qui découpe un morceau de
l'adn et quitte le remplace avec un avec
un morceau 9 qui marchera mieux qui sera
pas muté et ses 7 ans parce que ça
j'imagine bien j'imagine que c'est
faisable si on a une cellule qu'on
modifie la donne dans cette cellule mais
si on veut on peut cibler genre des
cellules dans le corps humain ou quelque
chose comme ça ouais généralement alors
du coup va falloir prendre des virus qui
vont plutôt infecté tel type ou tel type
de cellules par exemple après
effectivement par exemple dans le
cerveau l'idée c'est ça va cibler des
cellules mais après ça va se répandre
sur quelques centaines de micromètres tu
vois donc c'est pas énorme ça va pas
aller dans tous le cerveau directement
hockey par contre si tu as des virus qui
sont
enfin en fait ça dépend complètement de
ton mode d'injection le cerveau ce qui
est ultra compliqué c'est que il ya une
barrière et
il ya une barrière entre le cerveau et
la circulation sanguine qui fait que
tout est vraiment hyper fitr est donc
typiquement si tu mettais un virus dans
la circulation sanguine
ils se retrouveraient pas dans le
cerveau qu il y reste collé un peu
partout dans le corps mais il n'y aurait
pas dans le cerveau donc pour avoir
quelque chose qui s'exprime dans le
cerveau faut aller l'injecter
directement dedans et à quel point ça
c'est maîtriser cette technique est ce
que ça fait un peu c'est complètement
fou que ça fait ça un peu peur aussi
c'est relativement fins way s'est
relativement bien maîtrisé après je peux
pas te parler de toutes les thérapies
géniques partout mais tu as le cerveau
ce qui est maîtrisée c'est qu'au final
il y as tu un gect ça un endroit précis
dans le cerveau et du coup c'est vrai
que ce qu'ils maîtrisaient sais que ça
va pas très loin de toute façon
donc ça va pas aller dans tout corps ça
va pas être systémique
allez partout partout etc après il ya
toutes les thérapies cellulaires ou là
c'est au lieu d'injecter un virus et
injectent des cellules ont été à toutes
les thérapies géniques où là c'est
plutôt en injecte dans le sens et puis
ça va un peu plus partout là où c'est
vrai que ça va demander beaucoup plus de
réflexion et de deux tests et des
analyses mais tu vois par exemple dans
le cerveau ben voilà ça va pas aller
très loin
on sait que c'est super contenu est
typiquement donc la thérapie génique
qu'on avait mis en place dans notre dans
notre labo l'idée c'est de la testé sur
des humains qui vont avoir une chirurgie
où on va leur enlever un morceau de
cerveau on a prévu leur enlever un
morceau de cerveau de base
le morceau qui est épileptique avec avec
donc normalement l'épilepsie ça se
traite avec des médicaments
donc il n'y a aucun souci généralement
la plupart des formes
tu prends un antiépileptique et s'est
résolu il ya des formes qui sont
résistantes aux anti épileptique et là
dans ces cas là si c'est un endroit qui
peut être tripoter entre guillemets par
des chirurgiens
on va faire une une chirurgie ablative
donc on va enlever un morceau du cerveau
et le patient si tu veux va se réveiller
de la chirurgie guéri de l'épilepsie et
et sans séquelles ce qui est assez
magique si tu le dis moi ça me fait
c'est un truc de malade c'est magique
pour moi c'est de là mais je sais c'est
qu'en dise ah tu dis mais comment c'est
possible
et du coup l'idée ce serait d'injecter
en tout cas de tester cette thérapie
génique d'injecter des patients qui vont
de toute façon avoir une chirurgie si tu
veux et de se dire bah on peut leur
injecter ça si jamais ça marche pas ou
si jamais on voit que c'est pas terrible
comme thérapie finalement bas ils
peuvent avoir leur chirurgie on leur
enlève leurs morceaux de cerveau qui
créent des crises et puis eux ce sera
comme si de rien était ok et du coût des
travaux que tu as fait prendre plus de
clous ils ont été appliquées pour
l'instant en médecine alors pendant ma
thèse on a on a trouvé deux mutations
donc ce qui est cool c'est que ça a été
appliqué directement c'est à dire qu'il
ya de familles qui ont été diagnostiqués
c'est fou quand même donc ça c'est
chouette
ça c'est plutôt pas mal après tout le
reste c'était un peu plus théorique
c'est à dire c'était essayer de
comprendre comment c'était philippe si
la marche est cetera donc ça n'a pas été
super appliquée est par contre ce que
j'ai fait pendant mon post doc
donc c'était une étude pré clinique sur
des rats pour développer une thérapie
génique et on a déposé un brevet est
normalement si tout va bien ça va aller
ceux des plus développés en clinique
donc ça n'a pas été appliqué là tout de
suite ça sera probablement appliquée par
contre ça sera appliquée dans une
dizaine d'années parce que l'échelle de
temps elle est juste complètement folle
j'imagine le prendre pas mal de
précaution faut prendre toutes les
précautions faut les virus là nous on
les fabriquer nous-mêmes tu vois dans
nos labos si ça passe chez l'humain faut
aller fabriquer sa dans des boîtes qui
ont des niveaux de sécurité super en
force et c'est pour être sûr que la
pureté du truc et maximum
il ya du coup un protocole à respecter
va y avoir des patients à recruter et
c'est donc ce que c'est c'est très très
long mais mais c'est possible que ça
passe là dessus et dans mon labo on
était pas mal à bosser sur des thérapies
géniques il y avait une dizaine de
thérapie génique en tout qui était en
route dans le labo donc
voilà si tout va bien il y en a bien une
un moment qui va qu'il fallait sortir
dans cinq dix ans je pensais
et ouais et et croquante quoi tu vois ça
a peu évolué à la thérapie génique pense
qu'il y aura beaucoup de découvertes à
venir etc cela met franchement j'avais
pas mal les choses ou away complètement
complètement j'y crois j'y crois à fond
en fait on s'est rendu compte d'un d'une
chose c'est que la génétique joue
vachement sur sur le traitement
c'est-à-dire que même quand tu prends un
médicament suivante à génétique donc en
gros chaque personne on a tous les mêmes
gènes d'accord on a tous le même nombre
de gènes on a tous les mêmes gènes c'est
un peu comme une bibliothèque ce tu veux
on a tous la même bibliothèque avec les
mêmes livres mais par contre certains
vont avoir des versions différentes mais
des bouquins il va y avoir des fautes de
frappe des mots différents etc
et du coup ça ce que ça va faire c'est
que certains médicaments vont agir mieux
certaines personnes parce que les
récepteurs vont être plus actifs ou l'
inverse
donc du coup ce qui fait quand toi tu
prends un médicament ça se trouve ça te
fait plus d'effet que quelqu'un d'autre
ou moins d'effet que quelqu'un est donc
déjà la génétique est super impliqué
dans l'est la thérapie en général et la
thérapie génique vraiment je pense que
il ya moyen déjà 2 2 c'est un moyen de
faire un retour en arrière sur des
maladies génétiques donc de réussir à
rendre des personnes entre guillemets
voile afin de guérir des personnes qui
ont des maladies génétiques donc ça
c'est génial tu vois si on sait quelle
maladie c'est on peut on peut la cible
et
et enfin franchement la thérapie génique
j'y crois j'y crois moi il ya énormément
de variations qu'il ya la variation
injecter un virus qui va qui va régler
ça avec un gène en entier un gène entier
qui règle le truc il ya la version crise
parquet l'a vraiment une espèce de
petits ciseaux génétique petits ciseaux
génétique qui va aller couper couper ce
qui va pas et remplacé talent et
thérapie cellulaire aussi donc là ça va
être injecté des cellules saines chez
des patients qui ont des cellules un peu
endommagé donc souvent ça peut être des
types de cellules souches tu vois qu'ils
vont se remettre à reproduire par
exemple delà de la moelle épinière ou
des trucs comme ça et tu vois pas ce que
donc tu dis que l'adn de quelqu'un
affecte beaucoup le médicament fin de la
prise en charge qui va voir et du coup
ça pose la question du séquençage adn
du coup il y aura une énorme opportunité
en tout cas en terme de santé à
séquencer puis systématiquement les adn
des patients ouais
et ça ça c'est dur il ya du pour et du
contre en fait déjà il ya il ya encore
plein plein de choses ja alors je sais
pas si tu as entendu parler de toine
thys oui admis tous ces trucs là il ya
énormément de sites ou qui te propose de
diagnostic est déjà génétiquement plein
de choses le souci c'est que déjà il n'y
a pas d'accompagnement médical qu'il ya
des gens qui se voit diagnostiquer de
maladie ou de probabilité d'avoir une
maladie qui veut rien dire
et là ça va te parler complètement c'est
à dire que quand on dit tu as 70 % de
risque d'avoir une maladie ça veut pas
dire que tu vas l'avoir nécessairement
donc c'est chaud pour ça ce qui est
compliqué aussi c'est qu'il ya plein
plein de
de maladies on sait qu'elles sont
génétiques mais on sait pas encore
quelles sont les causes quels sont les
gènes impliqués
du coup parfois tu vois on peut très
bien le dire bah t'as pas de risque pour
cette maladie là alors qu'en fait tu là
mais c'est juste que tu as une mutation
sur un jeune qu'on n'a pas encore
détecté comme responsable donc pour
l'instant c'est difficile c'est l'est
vraiment les balbutiements et ce qui
peut être dangereux aussi c'est que
imagine c'est à ta vie déjà un peu tout
tracé ça devient un peu gattaca tu vois
tu sais exactement ce qui va t'arriver
quand ça va t'arriver
c'est voilà c'est est ce que tu as envie
de savoir que tu as 70% de risques
d'avoir telle maladie je suis pas sûr
mais par contre voilà c'est bien parfois
génétiquement de se dire si tu as une
maladie chronique importante où tu
prends un médicament assez régulièrement
et a besoin de savoir si quel est
l'effet tu vois du médicament tu peux
séquences et éventuellement les gènes
impliqués les jeux le récepteur par
exemple à ce médicament là où on voit là
mais le reste
le séquençage de tout le génome c'est
s'est encore compliquée je pense que ça
se trouve dans 50 ou 100 ans ça sera une
vision complètement différente de la
chose mais
mais il ya ça et il ya aussi un niveau
qui est un peu plus compliqué c'est
qu'il ya la génétique donc là c'est
vraiment le code génétique comme lire un
bouquin avec les petites lettres à tcg
qui code pour quelque chose
et après il ya l'épigénétique mais temps
probablement entendu parler
l'épigénétique c'est en gros 1
comment compliquer les choses c'est à
dire ok tu as gènes hla mai
l'épigénétique va céder niveau
d'activation du gène donc parfois il ya
un gène qui est là qui existe une
version de ce jeune là mais en fait ce
jeune et active et inactive et chez toi
et l'épigénétique on commence un petit
peu tu vas avoir commencé à marcher tout
mais je pense qu'il ya ça aussi qui
changent énormément la donne pour les
maladies génétiques et qui fait que
certaines personnes risquent d'avoir une
maladie qui n'auront développeront
jamais au final et
et d'autres qu'on peut être moins de
risques mais qui finalement vont la
développer plus sûrement donc tu veux il
ya tellement de niveaux de complexité
pour l'instant c'est encore le début je
pense on en sait pas grand chose et
c'est c'est assez excitant recherche et
je pense que ça va ça va déboucher sur
plein de choses mais ça risque de
déboucher aussi sur beaucoup des rives
dont il va falloir faire attention
séquence et on a gun non j'avoue que
j'ai eu
j'ai eues j'aurais pu parce que je sais
quand ces séquences et des gènes tout le
temps
le truc c'est juste que à l'époque j'ai
l'impression d'être super vieille quand
l'islam mais la génétique ça avance m et
à une vitesse de malades
typiquement dans les années 90 quand on
faisait une thèse ont séquencé peut-être
quelques milliers de bases moi j'ai fait
plusieurs gènes pendant ma tête donc
c'était c'était chaque gène faisait je
sais pas on va dire 9000 base à
séquencer maintenant on en voit ça on
envoie les échantillons d adn à des
grosses boîtes qui vont faire un
séquençage du génome entier est la seule
limitation au final c'est les machines
d' analyses et après derrière les
humains a cherché à comprendre où sont
les mutations et à quoi elle
correspondait tout mais moi je n'ai pas
fait parce qu'à l'époque c'était exempt
par exemple donc en gros un gène est
divisé par petits morceaux qui sont
exprimés et du coup ces petits morceaux
font quelques centaines de bases et du
coup moi je faisais exemple par exemple
tu veux un gène ça m'aurait pris ça me
prenait du temps à séquencer donc je
n'aurais jamais pu séquencer tout le
monde appelle à la patience
ouais il m'aurait fallu plus que matin
et tu compte pas le faire
non non je pense pas en fait
des fois je me dis ça m'intéresserait de
voir comment ca marche twenty sous et
demi par exemple ce qu'ils font c'est
qu'ils vont passer quand c'est partout
ouais y regardent en tout cas c'est ce
qu'ils faisaient
j'ai pas regardé tout récemment mais
généralement les les boîtes qui font ça
c'est pas du séquençage cent pour cent
du génome ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils
regardent à des endroits où il ya des
mutations très très commune pour
certaines maladies
dans les gènes communs et dans les
mutations commune et regarde et il voit
la version du gène que tu as et 10 basse
c'est une version plus ou moins risqués
ou pas à risque etc
du coup ce qui est un petit peu un petit
peu dangereux entre guillemets c'est que
il ya il ya des choses qu'on connaît pas
et s'est laissée de côté donc il ya des
gens qui peuvent se dire amicale
je risque rien je n'aurai jamais de
cancer du poumon parce que ou de cancer
je sais que je sais pas quoi parce que
voilà je suis j'ai pas de risque et puis
en fait qu'il ya un risque mais c'est
jusqu'à un risque qu'on connaissait
quand pas encore en génétique comme
qu'elle du coup faut prendre la d aide
avec des pincettes exactement mais ses
retranchements encore ouais voilà
exactement donc moi je pense que non je
le ferais pas mais bon on verra on en
reparlera dans un temps peut-être que
mais tu veux est ce que tu penses qu'il
faut envoyer jeudi il ya quarante pas
mal de questions éthiques qui se posent
autour du séquençage de l'adn
pas tant parce que tout ça est ce que tu
penses que il faudrait un peu si un
risque systématiquement faire du
séquençage de l'adn pour les gens à
risque ou non suspecte une made in
maladies génétiques
webb a typiquement il ya déjà énormément
de diagnostic prénatal notamment ça qui
est mis en route depuis depuis le début
dans les hôpitaux etc
c'est à dire quand on voit qu'il ya une
maladie génétique qui traînent dans la
famille très clairement quand
quant au tout début de la grossesse du
coup il ya un séquençage de ces gènes en
tout cas
quand on sait que s'est impliqué dans la
famille ou en tout cas des gènes des
gènes de risques et c'est donc ça ça
déjà c'est en route et c'est hyper je
trouve ça hyper important et après bon
c'est vrai qu'il ya des ce qui fait peur
c'est pas pour les maladies je trouve ça
je trouve ça bien tant que c'est médical
tant que tant qu'on utilise ça pour
rendre la vie meilleure ce qui fait peur
dans les dérives c'est de se dire voilà
commencé à avoir un peu des bébés sur
des bébés sur commande tu vois se dit ah
bah voilà tu fais une fécondation in
vitro tu commandes d'un petit garçon
avec des yeux bleus etc etc et là du
coup ses fins et le décès de l'eugénisme
tout simplement tu vois c'est la
sélection génétique quoi et c'est ça qui
risque de dériver quoi ouais alors ouais
je vois par la cia avec des amis de
parce qu'apparemment il y aurait des
recherches qui lit certains certains
gènes avec le feu les risques de
dépression mais voire même le bonheur
nature qui s'offre any way et du coup
battu si tu veux quand même ton enfant
d'être fatigué quand même que son enfant
soit heureux quoi et ça c'est une façon
un peu pas mal de le garantir parce que
qu'est-ce que tu penses quoi de ce à
quoi ça peut être pas mal mais encore
une fois est ce que est ce qu'il n'ya
pas un peu l'épigénétique qui va jouer
est ce que est ce que enfin en fait j'ai
l'impression qu'on arrive de plus en
plus dans une société où on veut tout
contrôler et et ça peut être pas mal si
on doit en contrôle de moins en moins de
maladies etc etc
mais c'est vrai que je sais pas si on
peut garantir le bonheur tu vois si un
gène qui permet effectivement d'être
plus résilient d'être peut-être un peu
plus heureux si tu veux d'être plus
enclins à être heureux que quelqu'un
d'autre je pense que d'une façon
générale il ya aussi les expériences de
la vie
il ya la vie de toute façon qui va se
passer et attention c'est le grand
moment très profond tu peux jamais rien
garantir dans la vie donc quelles que
soient la génétique que tu as je pense à
un moment il y aille à l'environnement
il ya le reste il ya des choses
auxquelles on est on est on est exposé
quand on est jeune et quand on est moins
jeunes aussi qui nous façonne
complètement en fait donc je sais pas
s'il ya moyen de garantir je recommence
ma phrase du coup je sais pas s'il ya un
moyen de garantir du coup le bonheur tu
vois où la non dépression d'une façon
générale
après même si génétiquement
il ya tout ce qu'il faut après est ce
que est ce que tu peux vraiment garantir
ça je suis pas sûr après je pense qu'il
y aura jamais rien aucune garantie mais
ouais ouais mais bon ça peut aider à
être mieux oui c'est c'est ça augmente
les chances à cette chose tout ça après
si c'est parfois aussi je pense que il
ya pas mal d'autres façons que de
modifier son génome pour être plus
heureux mais pour un nouveau-né si je
jouais que la question se passe à
interpeller good quelques questions
ouais non c'est intéressant c'est
intéressant bas c'est vrai que si ça
marche et si c'est en fait il faut que
ce soit ce qui compliquait que la
génétique c'est que souvent c'est pas un
gène c'est plein de jeunes qui vont ils
vont être responsable d un truc ou qui
vont qui vont au final
participer à quelque chose
et du coup c'est vrai que hors génétique
tu vois ces activations d'un gène d'un
autre et c est ce qu on arrivera à
sélectionner tu vois les meilleurs c'est
voit la fin c'est un peu ça c'est
toujours encore une fois c'est un peu de
l'eugénisme tu vois de de la sélection
du meilleur truc mais mais voilà c'est
vrai que 6,6 et je suis toujours pour si
c'est des trucs qui font du bien après
voilà faudrait pas non plus qu'on
fabrique des humains sur commande
tu vois je veux qu'eux ils soient plutôt
enclin à faire ça
ou pas être comme ça tu vas fin voilà et
puis je pense que dans la vie c'est pas
possible de toute façon pas question d
ouais c'est hyper des médias enfin est
ce que est ce que si tu fabriques
quelqu'un si tu pouvais contrôler les
gènes de quelqu'un et sa voix exactement
quelle personne tu dessines es tu vois
est ce que est ce que cette personne
serait exactement comme tu la veux et ce
qui est intéressant génétique en fait
c'est l'étude de jumeaux et les études
de jumeaux c'est c'est ce qui nous
permet de voir ce qui est lié à la
génétique ou ce qui est lié à
l'environnement parce que les jumeaux
ont un patrimoine génétique est 100%
semblable en tout cas au tout début et
l'idée c'est de se dire ben voilà les
choses qui font exactement pareil qui
avance pareil etc
c'est généralement génétique et les
choses qui sont différentes chez eux
c'est généralement c'est généralement
liés à l'environnement
j'ai eu des études de du tout doucement
à partir de jumeaux ou il montré que les
les vrais jumeaux avaient tendance à
avoir des avis politique beaucoup plus
semblables que des frères temps des
frères des frères et des soeurs frères
et soeurs fratrie way notamment adopté
ou du coup ça sujet a vraiment qu'il y
avait des fondements un peu génétique ou
croyances politiques à mais complètement
mes atouts en fait les jumeaux c'est
génial en génétique parce que ça permet
vraiment de voir qu'est-ce qui est
génétique est ski qu'est ce qui est de
l'environnement
et puis parfois même dans une même
famille on voit vraiment la différence
entre entre deux avec les jumeaux élevé
pareil les jumeaux les jumeaux séparés
et c'est entre les vrais jumeaux les
faux jumeaux
donc c'est hyper intéressant mais les
jumeaux vraiment c'est un cas vraiment
cool en génétique qui nous permet
d'analyser plein de choses ne vous
mettez pas en faire un laboratoire vous
surveille
exact oui c'est clair du coup je vois tu
veux parler encore un peu plus de ta
thèse ou de tarot cherchent eux non ben
non jeanne d'arc quoi surtout le truc à
se rappeler les gars jeanne d'arc était
probablement épileptique faire une
remarque sur jeanne d'arc c'est que les
neuroscientifiques faudra quand même un
peu plus vous bouger parce que le
diagnostic est un petit peu six en six
ans à ottawa mais t'as vu ça non mais a
le truc en fait qui complique avec
l'épilepsie
c'est que avant les épileptiques
souvent ils étaient ils étaient pris
pour des sorciers pour des gens possédés
pour enfin franchement les épileptiques
les personnes épileptiques ont pas eu de
chance pendant très longtemps parce que
comme c'est une maladie qui a si tu veux
des symptômes vraiment bizarre mais je
vois des la convulsion c'est quand même
c'est quand même ultra spéciale donc de
nos jours heureusement il ya la vraie il
ya la neuro il ya la médecine on voit ça
on analyse le cerveau ont fait d eux
j'ai donc c'est électroencéphalogramme
donc l'idée c'est de regarder l'activité
électrique du cerveau et de voir ce qui
se passe mais imagine ya il ya 200 ans
la personne qui convulsait qui se
mettaient à bavay mousse et de la bouche
bouger dans tous les sens être secoué
tout généralement c'est un acte divin
il ya eu une période où le disais c'est
une sorcière
tu vas en écosse il avait une façon de
vérifier à sa j'adore
si si les gens étaient sorcier ou pas
donc c'était dans le château des dindes
edimbourg donc je sais pas si tu l'as
déjà visité il est tout en haut d'un
rocher une colline en fait il est hyper
en hauteur et donc du coup les douves du
château elle fond je ne sais pas combien
de mètres de haut mais c'est juste
complètement dingo et un baiia de l'eau
est en fait le procès des gens pour
sorcellerie c'était de les jeter par
dessus donc board dans les douves du
château
s'il survivait c'est qu'ils étaient in
north y survivaient c'est qu'ils étaient
possédés ou soir donc peine de mort donc
c'est magique par contre s'il mourait ça
prouve et qu'effectivement il était
innocent et qu'en fait c'étaient pas des
sorciers et donc bah pas de bol vous
êtes mort mais en fait vous êtes
innocent j'adore quand j'ai visité le
château chela mais non c'est pas
possible
et ces prothèses qui se pensent que
c'est des jugements assez efficace
j'adore j'adore à tes morts étaient
vivants bah ouais donc c'est que tu es
coupable bombe à peine de mort est
souvent en fait à cette époque là bas il
y avait
il ya des épileptiques malheureusement
des personnes qui avaient l'épilepsie
qui sont qui sont passés par dessus bord
parce que on y pensait posséder sorcier
tu as faim tous les trucs super mal
excuses on fait des statistiques sur les
noms voir des personnes épileptiques
vraiment sorti avec un survécu à la
chute
non mais non mais le coût des survies
elle a chuté tout quoi et tu expliques
tu te comment vous pouvez on pouvait
faire ça quoi enfin voilà donc
donc il ya des pauvres malheureux
conduit passer par dessus bord alors
qu'ils avaient juste une maladie
neurologique quoi cette 7e jeu combien
de personnes
l'épilepsie c'est un pour cent de la
population 1 % général c'est énorme
c'est vraiment énorme le truc c'est que
parfois il ya des épilepsies qui vont
qui vont se résoudre tout seul notamment
l'épilepsie chez les enfants en fait
comme ça vient du fait que il ya un trop
plein d'électricité à un moment
généralement les cerveaux qui sont soit
en développement comme les cerveaux des
enfants où il ya plein de neurones qui
vont se mettre à mourir d'autres qui
vont pousser qui vont qui vont un peu se
réorganiser le réseau se réorganise tout
le temps donc du coût généralement bas
ça peut créer de l'épilepsie qui se
résorbera tout seul et chez les vieux
donc
il ya une prévalence plus de personnes
âgées qui vont avoir qui vont faire de
l'épilepsie tout simplement parce que
ils vont avoir des neurones qui vont
mourir ils vont avoir des réseaux
neuronaux qui vont un petit peu ce sera
fabriquée tu vois se réorganiser
différemment après un avc
tu as un gros gros risques d'épilepsie
parce que l'avc ça tue quand même des
neurones et du coup le cerveau qui
serait organisé dès qu'ils seraient
organise généralement c'est un petit peu
le bordel et est malheureusement sacré
d'épilepsie donc et de la lepi les
petites que tu as étudié génétique là ça
fera toujours combien de personne en
particulier
là c'était très très peu combien de
personnes je pourrais même pas te
répondre
moi je travaille sur une trentaine de
familles mais le truc qui était hyper
intéressant c'est que c'est une forme
génétique certes donc c'est très très
très peu de monde mais par contre
c'était un mécanisme différent
du coup l'idée c'était de se dire comme
c'est un mécanisme différent
l'analyse et ça va permettre de
comprendre peut-être certaines formes
d'épilepsie qui sont pas génétique mais
comprenez pas jusque là tu vois ou de
mieux comprendre des formes qu'on
comprenait déjà un peu mais mais
d'apporter une connaissance
supplémentaire donc souvent génétique en
fait c'est ça l'intérêt
ça paraît stupide parce qu'on travaille
sur des échantillons minuscule sur des
des familles tu vois gens très peu de
familles qui ont une épilepsie
finalement assez rares et tout mais mais
ces études là ça te permet d'appliquer
sa après au plus grand nombre et à une
échelle un peu plus importante et ça te
permet un plus grand une plus grande
connaissance des maladies généralement
comme vos jumeaux que vous aimez étudier
et à ce que ça des liens avec d'autres
maladies comme parkison ou alzheimer
alors vas tu as toujours un risque en
fait l'épilepsie c'est vraiment soit
elle arrive tout seul soit effectivement
elle arrive seconde herman parce que
quand il ya des maladies neurologiques
ou il ya effectivement des neurones qui
vont mourir là il ya des risques
d'épilepsie
donc là effectivement ça va être des
petits secondaire qui sera due à à une
réorganisation pas du tout français une
réorganisation neuronale tu vois donc il
ya il faut vraiment faire la différence
entre épilepsie qui arrivent en seconde
herman épilepsie qui est vraiment tu
vois la maladie seul que la personne
aura seulement dans ce cas là et parfois
aussi truc important il ya des gens qui
peuvent faire des crises d'épilepsie
par exemple quand ils prennent des
drogues quand ils prennent quand ils
boivent trop d'alcool ou sous le stress
aussi ça peut arriver
généralement on dit une personne qui
fait une crise d'épilepsie et pas
forcément une personnes épileptiques eux
c'est un diagnostic d'épilepsie quand
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
récurrent et qui n'a pas de
de raisons tu veux si si tu prends la
drogue et eut fait une crise d'épilepsie
tepa épileptique parce que c'est la
drogue qui a causé l'épilepsie par
contre si tu étais là tu demande rien à
personne et boum tu fais une crise et
puis ça se reproduit régulièrement là
vraiment tu pourras être classifié comme
épileptique accueil et à quel point
est-ce que les recherches en épilepsie
sont utiles ou transférables à d'autres
problèmes comme quand park celle
d'alzheimer comme la dépression basse et
transférables dans le sens où on étudie
comment les neurones
discutent entre eux entre tu vois donc
c'est toujours c'est toujours utile de
savoir ça de savoir notamment tu vois le
g qui est l'outil de détection des piles
de l'épilepsie
je crois qu'il a il n'est pas mal
utilisé
je crois que c'est pour alzheimer mais
j'ai peut-être dire une bêtise mais ça
peut être utilisé pour d'autres choses
donc voilà en fait en euro à partir du
moment où on apprend comment les
neurones ne marche comme c'est vraiment
un réseau les neurones c'est hyper c'est
des bestioles vraiment super super
susceptible en fait et dès que tu as une
petite un petit déséquilibre dans le
réseau tu risques d'avoir un truc qui se
cassent complètement la figure ok donc
du coup c'est bien de savoir exactement
comment les choses se passent comment
tout se passe comment ça marche
sachant qu'on sait pas encore exactement
à 100% comment le cerveau marche 10 à ce
que l inverse moi j'aurais dit le
cerveau et un probablement robuste qu'il
ya des trucs qui pète dans tous les sens
on contrôle pas grand chose boucles au
vent on arrive quand même à rester
nous-mêmes peu oui on y arrive alors
c'est ça le truc c'est que d'un côté on
y arrive d'un autre côté les neurones
entre eux sont hyper susceptible tu vois
c'est à dire que par exemple l'épilepsie
moi ce que je trouve est fantastique
c'est que les patients qui font beaucoup
de crises quotidienne ouais donc les
patients qui subissent une chirurgie qui
je récupérer les morceaux de cerveau
quand j'étais en thèse
donc j'y allais à l'opération tu vas y
avait quelqu'un avec un crâne ouvert qui
est en train de se faire enlever un
morceau de cerveau moi je récupère un
bout de cerveau je retournais dans mon
labo avec ce bout de cerveau
grand moment de la dette et ce qui est
fascinant c'est qu'en fait donc
l'épilepsie c'est un court-circuit donc
tes neurones c'est le barbecue c'est y
subissent un barbecue et du cou
typiquement il y avait ce cas d'une
jeune fille qui faisait 6 crise donc
avec convulsions et tout par jour donc
c'est énorme
ll avait du coup le bout de son cerveau
donc si tu veux il ya un endroit dans le
cerveau qui démarrent les crises et là
ce bout là pour elle il était
complètement complètement cramé il est
vraiment cramer au sens propre c'est à
dire que les neurones moi j'ai récupéré
mes morceaux de cerveau de cette jeune
fille est en fait quand tu fais une
analyse dessus il ya plus de neurones et
sont tous morts et ce qui est magique
c'est que cette jeune fille elle était
elle-même qu' il n'y avait pas deux il
n'y avait pas trop de séquelles liées à
sa etc
elle s'est fait enlever un morceau de
cerveau et elle ressortait de la guérit
sans séquelles en étant elle même
donc c'est magnifique c'est vraiment et
souvent il ya ya ya des phénomènes
d'adaptation de compensation on appelle
ça ce qui est génial à la fois parce que
c'est magnifique
tu vois quand tu vois ça tu dis mais
enfin cesser complètement foot un bout
de ton cerveau qui est complètement en
train de partir en barbecue et ça change
rien enfin ça te fais des crises mais ça
change rien à sa personnalité et à ta
mémoire apte à qui tu fais quoi par
contre ce qui est horrible en euros
c'est que les souris ont généralement
des mécanismes de compensation encore
plus développé que les humains et ce
qu'il fait quand tu veux étudier des
maladies neurologiques chez les animaux
que tu fais des modèles des modèles
animaux donc généralement tu prends un
gène tue-le tue-le qu as tu vois tu le
tue le rang inexistant chez cet animal
il efficace donc du coup ça te fait un
modèle animal ou ce gène hla et muté et
un coups sûrs d'eux mêmes trois coups
sur trois trois coups sûrs quatre pardon
là tu vas avoir des mécanismes de
compensation qui se met en route
donc du coup tu vas avoir un modèle
animal que tu mets deux ans et demi à
développer est en fait la souris elle va
aller parfaitement nickel et hans qui
est ultra petit pose problème aux
recherches c'est que bah du coup va
falloir refaire un nouvel un nouveau
modèle etc etc
et parfois ça ça complique les
recherches sur le cerveau donc c'est top
mais à la fois ça complique
et c'est vrai que voilà on rebondit on
reste en reste qui on est et le cerveau
c'est c est fantastique et ça c'est une
faculté qui intéresse beaucoup les
informaticiens
aujourd'hui ce qu'on a des systèmes de
plus en plus complexes et distribué est
ce qu'on veut c'est que même si une
partie de d'internet pète que c'est
comme ça on veut que le système continue
à fonctionner comme il devait
fonctionner ouais ça s'adresse à un
sacré mystère ya des redondances il ya
plein de choses en fait fin il ya il ya
des circuits détourné donc en haut c'est
à l'impression en fait que quoi que tu
fasses il ya un peu une back up qui se
passe ce qui se passe aussi avec le
cerveau faut jamais oublier c'est qu'il
est il est doublé il ya deux hémisphères
est typiquement cette jeune fille là
qu'a eu plein de crises d'épilepsie
probablement l'autre hémisphère à
compenser pour celui qui était en train
de se faire griller
mais après ces histoires des deux
émissaires j'ai des trucs ou si on
couple et les trucs entre les deux
hémisphères t des trucs assez bizarre
avec les pieds de deux personnalités
différentes et du cerveau mais il se
passe plein de choses en fait c'est pas
il ya des épilepsies pour les pour les
guérir entre guillemets en couple et les
les connexions entre les deux
hémisphères parce qu'en gros il ya un
hémisphère qui lance le feu et si tu le
coupe du coup l'épilepsie elle pourra
pas se propager
mais en fait s'il y a tellement de il ya
tellement de trucs on n'a pas encore
tout compris quoi et je pense que on est
on est pas loin d'avoir tout compris
mais il ya encore vachement de travail
et c'est ça qui est passionnant avec le
cerveau c'est que t'as jamais fait le
tour en fait c'est passionnant qu est ce
que tu suis encore ce qui se passe en
recherche
alors j'essaye un petit peu la
différence c'est que avant j'allais lire
tu vois des articles scientifiques sur
l'épilepsie sur ma forme de deux
d'épilepsie de boulot et c'est
maintenant comme je fais de la
communication scientifique je lis
beaucoup plus mais sur plein d'autres
choses
tu vois donc du coup je suis moi je suis
beaucoup moins en détail ce qui se passe
dans mon ancien domaine après j'ai
encore plein de collègues avec qui j'ai
des contacts donc c'est vrai que s'il ya
des trucs super nouveau je le vois
généralement généralement sur twitter
parce que maintenant ils sont tous sur
twitter
donc je vois ce qui se passe tu vois je
vois je vois passer les trucs et tout
donc je peux lire les articles ou ou ou
éventuellement voir un peu de loin ce
qui se passe mais basse quand tu fais de
la communication scientifique t'augmente
vachement le champ de des trucs que tu
lis les intérêts et c'est donc du coup
forcément il ya plus le temps pour lire
autant sur le reste du coup quand tu as
enfin pourquoi est-ce que tu as décidé
d'arrêter la recherche alors plusieurs
raisons la première c'est que
j'avais c'est pas forcément la première
en terme d'importance mais j'ai pas
forcément eu le nombre de publier deux
publications qu'il aurait fallu que j'ai
pour être chercheuse je pense tout
simplement parce que mon premier post
doc a pas été super super efficace en
publie mon deuxième c'était de l'hymne
vivo sur des rats donc autant dire que
j'ai passé quatre ans et demi sur un
article et malheureusement je me suis
fait complètement volé ma place sur la
liste d'auteurs donc en gros la liste
d'auteurs c'est hyper important d'être
premier ou dernier pour être schématique
et là sur mon article c'est mon étudiant
en thèse qui est premier parce qu'il a
demandé à mon boss et que j'étais dans
un labo assez sexiste qui considérait
que les mecs avaient un peu plus de deux
droits que les nanas on va dire donc moi
j'étais bonne à
à former tout le monde mais par contre
quand il s'agissait d'avoir mon nom est
d'avoir le crédit dont travaille pas au
final c'est mon étudiant qui l'a
récupéré
c'est horrible donc c'était assez
horrible mais en même temps la réseau si
pour laquelle je suis parti c'est que
c'était un milieu super compétitif ce
que j'adorais ce cheval je quittais pas
la recherche parce que c'était
compétitif mais du coup rien que dans
mon labo on était entre 8 et 10 à
développer des thérapies géniques
donc je me suis un peu 10 niveaux impact
là est ce que vraiment ça change quelque
chose si je travaille là ou pas ouais tu
t y soit bah oui et en fait ça changeait
pas grand chose enfin il ya ce que je
sois là ou que je ne sois pas là si je
partais il y avait un nouveau post doc
qui allait prendre qu'à aller prendre ma
place le boulot allait avancer le projet
allait continuer tu vois
enfin la différence se verrait pas et à
côté j'ai développé par 900 j'avais des
possibilités de bosser sur le
développement international du festival
et ça faisait des années que j'avais
envie de le faire et là je me suis dit
bas en terme d'impact je préfère
augmenter le nombre de pays où panov
sainz est présent et donner la
possibilité à plein de chercheurs et
chercheuses de présenter leurs travaux
et de faire de la vulgarisation plutôt
que de rester dans mon labo et au final
de faire un job que n'importe qui
d'autre qui étaient là-bas en tout cas
beaucoup d'autres mondes qui était dispo
pour ça aurait pu faire tu vois ça tu
manques la recherche ou content d'eux
non je suis contente en fait en fait ce
qui était très très dur c'est que les
quatre cinq dernières années
bah en fait les dix dernières années
pour être honnête j'ai travaillé sur les
animaux et les toutes dernières c'était
sur les rats et les rabats c'est ultra
mignon
c'est très très dur de travailler sur
les animaux et est en plus niveau santé
moi j'étais devenu allergique donc en
plus de détester travailler sur les
animaux gt ça me rendait complètement
malade tu vois que ça aurait besoin
non mais les deux dernières années je
les ai fait j'étais au bout de ma vie à
chaque fois de croiser un rat quoi donc
du coup j'étais soulagé en fait tu vois
de terminer parce que voilà enfin pour
ma santé c'était pas bon les rats enfin
travailler que des animaux à la fois
c'est bien parce que on travaille sur un
projet qui est bien on se dit c'est du
pré clinique donc là je suis vraiment
très très proche d appliquer ça mais
d'un autre côté bah ouais tu travailles
avec avec un animal quoi donc
bah c'est dur du coup va transitionner
un petit peu vert va pas être simple
d'être au service du coup ta ta ta tête
tu étais là pour la première édition des
prix top 100 comment s'est passé ouais
ouais ouais en fait j'ai rejoint
l'équipe peut-être deux mois après après
le début
du lancement de l'organisation en fait
j'ai rejoint l'équipe en janvier 2013
ok pour la création du premier festival
en mai 2013
ok donc ouais complètement là depuis
depuis quasi le début quoi hockey et
donc à ce moment là tu étais post-doc
way j'étais post doc je venais tout
juste de commencer mon deuxième post doc
sur la thérapie génique ayew ciel à
londres et puis et puis là un jour
j'ouvre ma boite mail ça faisait 15
jours que j'avais commencé mon post doc
et je vois un mail de paito sainz qui
recherchent des volontaires pour les
aider à organiser le festival
là dessus je vois le mail j'appelle
direct ce que j'ai toujours aimé
organiser des trucs
enfin voilà l'orga l'événementiel et
puis la communication ça m'intéressait
j'avais encore rien fait mais ça
m'intéressait et là j'ai eu un coup de
bol monstrueux c'est à dire qu'au départ
il cherchait quelqu'un pour
pour animer des soirées dans un bar sur
le cerveau conçue orgue et voix l'a donc
hors gamme mais pas les animés pas faire
les présentations mais géré pendant
trois soirs en fait les présentations
trouver des intervenants trouver un bar
et c est au moment où j'ai appelé deux
heures avant il y avait la personne qui
gérait
to you ciel donc mon université là où
j'étais qui venait tout juste de
d'abandonner le truc enfin ok ok et est
donc à mes timing mais plus que parfaite
c'est à dire que c'était dingue au jeu
les appels je leur dis bah voila vous
cherchez des volontaires des bénévoles
ils m'ont dit bah oui d'ailleurs est ce
que tu préfères plutôt que juste
organiser trois soirée dans un bar est
ce que ça te va de manager l'équipe ii
you ciel il y avait des équipes de
logiciels il ya trois équipes ça faisait
trois bars 9 événements en tout est ce
que ça te va je leur avais dit mais
ouais carrément et tout et voilà et du
coup j'ai sauté dans l'aventuré c'est
vrai que j'ai adoré ce à quoi enfin
c'était c'était un truc de fou et j'ai
créé du coup enfin je les ai bien bien
pousser et bien bien saoulé pour pour le
lancer le truc à l'international et du
coup lancé la france juste après la
première édition la page facebook
printers france a été créée en juin 2013
dont la fin est exactement on a fait un
meeting sur sûre qu'est ce qu'on fait
après et ils m'ont donné la corde de
faire ça et du coup je suis sorti de là
j'ai créé la page en mode ça y est ça
existe du coup la première édition était
grande comment ce dvd avec montebourg
alors en terme de base
je crois qu'on avait une trentaine de
bars on à être trois soirées trois ils
s'étaient london oxford et cambridge on
avait à temps parce que j'ai un peu 50
millions de stade dans la tête 1 av oui
alors c'est une association étudiante à
ce moment où il s'était alors non
c'était
c'était pas une asso son n'était on
était tous scientifique mais il ya plus
de post doc 2
que d'étudiants hockey et c'était mais
du coup ça c'est quand les gens sont
venus cette idée qu'en fait c'est un
groupe de potes qui s'est dit on va
lancer sa way exactement en fait ces
deux donc les deux fondateurs c'est donc
michel amat skins et praveen paul
c'était deux chercheurs en post doc
qui était imperial college à londres et
en fait j'avais fait une journée portes
ouvertes de leur labo et
où il ya eu des patients de nos maladies
neuro neurodégénérative qui sont venus
voir ce qui se passait en recherche et c
est en fait là ils ont eu un déclic qui
sont dit mais les gens sont super
intéressé par la recherche
sauf que le gros problème de
de la recherche c'est que venir dans un
labo c'est quand même c'est quand même
ultra compliqué et donc
du coup ils sont dit mais comment est ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour faire venir
les chercheurs plutôt que de faire venir
le public au à la recherche en fait
faire venir la recherche au public c'est
trop basse
là où ils se trouvent dans les bars
surtout que en angleterre en fait le pub
c'est vraiment un lieu de vie c'est pas
c'est pas un lieu où tu bois juste c'est
vraiment un lieu où tu te poses tival
dimanche en famille
tu peux passer ton samedi après mais
là-bas à boire une bière ou pas te poser
faire des jeux
des jeux de société voire tous tes potes
et steria vraiment une une
une habitude de vie autour du peuple qui
est hyper importante tu vois et donc
voilà donc ils sont dit bah on va faire
ça dans des pubs après clairement c'est
pas nouveau dans le sens où il ya eu de
la science dans les pubs depuis et dans
les bars et dans les cafés depuis que
les cafés existe c'est on pense au
procope à paris à odéon c'est là où il y
avait tous les philosophes qui venaient
se se retrouver pour parler philosophie
et sciences à l'époque c'est un super
vieux café à paris c'est le premier café
de paris pascal et way we hill et il est
à odéon il ya ya ya plein de trucs
placardées partout sur sur les
philosophes à l'époque qui venait et
donc en fait on n'a rien inventé pour
baldersheim très clairement ça fait des
siècles que ça existe mais l'idée c'est
que en angleterre en fait il ya deux
grosses culture il ya la culture du
peuple et il ya la culture du festival
ouais il ya énormément de festivals de
musique en angleterre et notamment il y
en a un je sais pas si tu en as déjà
entendu parler ces deux-là steinberg
c'est un festival de musique qui se vend
les places se vendent sans que le line
up soit soit communiqué donc en gros
chaque année tu as des gens qui se
regroupent c'est flippant avoir par par
une dizaine de personnes tu vois sur des
ordinateurs à rafraichir la page pour
essayer d'avoir des places et en gros en
deux heures le truc est sold out et si
tu as réussi à avoir une place c'est ses
limites miraculeux et du coup l'idée de
paille nof zion c'était de se dire bah
on va faire un peu la même chose mais
avec de la sueur c'est donc donc voilà
donc plusieurs scènes en même temps au
tour donc la première année parce que je
digresse mais comme c c'est un interview
long jeu droite digresser fais ce que tu
veux podcast c'est génial c'est génial
et donc effectivement au tout début on
avait trois villes
en tout on a eu trois mille quatre cents
personnes quand même en angleterre pour
la première édition ce qui est quand
même quand même pas mal et une trentaine
d'événements sans toutes ces même s'il
faut quoi
première édition comme ça a lancé le
truc c'est impressionnant ouais plus
d'ailleurs plus qu'une trentaine
soixantaine d'événements c'était une
trentaine par ville mais c'était
complètement chaud dans le sens où
franchement c'était une bande de
scientifiques qui avait aucune
connaissance en comment market en tuant
en rien quoi par contre on avait juste
envie que ça marche on avait envie de
partager la la science on avait envie
d'en parler et tout est du coup en fait
on s'est fait on a été choqués par le
succès du truc tu vois ça hyper bien
marché on s'est dit ok qu'est ce qu'on
fait maintenant
parce que tout le long en fait on était
vraiment en mode il faut que ça marche
il faut que ça marche et oui et pour
nous là le but c'était vraiment que ça
se passe que les gens soient heureux que
ça se passe bien et en fait on n'avait
pas du tout pensé à si ça marche qu'est
ce qu'on fait après tu vas en termes de
stratégie mais jamais quoi donc pareil
on n'avait pas pensé non plus avoir des
traces on avait pris des photos des
trucs comme ça mais par exemple de
demander à des journalistes de venir ou
même à des blogueurs ou tu vois des gens
qui on en parlerait et qui laisserait
des traces on n'avait pas donc après la
première année il y avait très peu de
traces mais de paito sense donc comme
moi j'ai monté la france déjà c'était un
concept anglais donc j'en disais ouais
ce que tu es sur ces anglais
ça a peut-être pas marché et toute la
bombe menés ont pensé un peu positif on
dit ça va le faire
plutôt que de trouver twh altitude à
mais complètement quoi c'était atroce
plutôt que de trouver toutes les raisons
pour lesquelles ça ne va pas marcher
trouvant le moyen de faire que ça marche
quoi et puis en plus j'avais zéro
j'avais zéro contenu sur ce qui s'était
passé tu vois ouais mais pas leur montre
et non je ne pouvais pas leur montrer
j'avais quelques photos soit mais
c'était en 2013 et à twitter en 2013
y'a pas à dire mais c'était quand même
vachement moins actif que maintenant
quoi tu vois maintenant les réseaux
sociaux là on a commencé à sortir le
programme c'est de la folie j'ai
l'impression que twitter en ce moment je
vois que pinto fine ça alors que je suis
plein d'autres gens qui font plein
d'autres choses mais je vois parler que
de paito sainz quoi donc
non mais c'est juste pour dire parce
qu'on enregistrait sa le 10 avril
mais prenons ce sera mise en ligne dans
sa peau de caste alors je crois qu'au
prix se fera le 28 avril juste comme ça
et donc là le 10 avril juste pour situer
le contexte le programme a été mise en
ligne
une somme en france ouais la france on a
mis en ligne le programme vendredi
dernier mais si pigments l'angleterre a
sorti ses tickets lundi là et puis il ya
d'autres que par exemple la suède a
commencé à sortir son programme mais
l'éthique et de la france qui sortent
lundi à l'éthique et de la belgique des
pays bas qui sortent lundi aussi en gros
là tous les pays commencent à publier
leurs programmes à publier leurs tickets
et où donc ça commence vraiment être la
grosse folie voilà est effectivement là
maintenant twitter on est juste en train
d' un peu noyé twitter donc twitter mais
twitter si tu m'écoutes je suis désolé
ce que cet entraîneur va falloir festin
trading wen
ouais exactement mais entraîne
généralement c'est cool on traîne
pendant le festival
ouais voilà généralement le surtout
qu'il ya plein de pays donc pendant
l'europe pendant le créneau horaire
européen ça ça traîne donc c'est plutôt
cool donc
donc voilà ouais non c'est celle là
aujourd'hui avait en gros c'était le
trou noir
photo du trou noir et doit donc pour en
revenir un petit peu donc en france donc
la première édition ça s'est passé
comment c'est bah écoute bien 2014
beaucoup plus petite que la première
édition anglaise tout simplement parce
que
il y avait tellement de réticences que
j'ai pas non plus voulu faire un truc de
fou tu vois on a fait avec les moyens du
bord à l'époque c'était beaucoup de
potes à moi qui qui avait eu la
gentillesse ou pas le choix on va dire
de s'embarquer dans le truc mais ouais à
ce moment là tu étais encore post-doc
que j'étais encore besoin qu'à londres
je suis rentré qu'il ya un an et demi
donc en gros il ya eu quatre éditions de
paille 900 à temps
quatre éditions de paito sense france où
j'étais encore en angleterre
l'année dernière c'était la cinquième et
c'était ma première année où j'étais
rentré en angleterre d'angleterre donc
ouais on a lancé le truc et on était à
paris lyon et bordeaux on a fait à peu
près 1000 participants la première année
donc tranquilles ou mai mais cool ça
voilà déjà mais exactement l'idée
c'était vraiment de lancer le truc ce
qui était un peu compliquée en france la
première année c'est qu'on a un logo
avec une pinte de bière alors c'est une
pinte de ce qu'on veut mais un peu
orange
donc du coup c'est vrai que au tout
début on n'était pas connue le concept
on n'avait pas forcément de preuves de
ce qui s'était passé et comment ça
s'était passé
et puis en france quand tu arrives tu
sais c'est toujours le gros sceptisme de
oui mais qu'ils quittaient machin et du
coup au départ c'était dur de convaincre
les intervenants c'était dur de
convaincre un peu tout le monde tu vois
les bars avaient peur de ne pas faire
assez de consommation les intervenants
avaient peur de parler qu'à des gens
bourrés les participants se disaient pas
une preuve ça aide c'est de la science
donc en gros on a touché beaucoup plus
de scientifiques 95% de scientifiques tu
vois et 5 % de pauvres gens qui ont été
forcés par leur pote à venir donc
violent fins et s est vraiment
différente maintenant quoi maintenant on
a à peu près 50% de gens qui font pas de
science actuellement donc probablement
que l'on fait mais qui en font pas
actuellement les chercheurs et
chercheuses sont toujours super content
de participer maintenant on en a même
qui voulait pas participer au début qui
nous disent j'ai bien fait participer
parce que parce que finalement c'était
super cool
donc voilà c'est complètement différent
mais c'est vrai que quand tu lances le
truc tu vois c'est une nouvelle
initiative
c'était encore à l'époque aussi où il
n'ya pas de temps de communication
scientifique que ça ouais même temps que
la première année que ma première année
de ma thèse dans 180 secondes
ouais 2014 ouais donc du coup tu vois
c'était encore l'année où bat fouet
c'était pas c'est pas si commun
maintenant voilà il ya de plus en plus
de s'initier à ti via la nrk quand même
mis un petit chapitre disons qu'il faut
faire de la dissémination etc etc
donc du coup on a des chercheurs qui
sont motivés on a un public qui commence
à entendre parler beaucoup de science
donc ouais ouais je vous dit la vérité
sur les nerfs la sema les nerfs amis
donc donc la nrpt pour expliquer ce cui
selanne ont donc c'est leur vie explique
qu est-ce que c'est parce que je suis
pas sûr de savoir alors à nerfs c'est si
je vais pas si je dis pas de bêtises
c'est agence nationale pour la recherche
ou de recherche pour la recherche en
gros c'est un l'organisme un très très
gros organismes de financement national
en france
l'idée c'est que donc quand on est
chercheur on demande toujours
des financements la vie du chercheur
c'est 95 % de son temps à demander des
financements et avant dans les
financements c'était purement le projet
de recherche comment on compte faire ses
recherches
qu'est-ce qu'on va acheter comme comme
comme machine quel personnel on va
utiliser etc etc et dans les films
demande de financement de la nr depuis
2018 et dans plein de demandes de
financement en europe aussi en
angleterre etc
maintenant il ya un chapitre sur les
gars comment vous comptez partager vos
recherches avec le public c'est trop
cool ça c'est génial c'est génial parce
que du coup ça fait que les chercheurs
qui étaient motivées avant mai
keep qui sentait un peu contraint de ne
pas le faire ou contraints par le temps
maintenant il ya une vraie raison de le
faire donc ça les libère un peu pour
faire de la des événements de
vulgarisation et tout et puis ça pousse
un peu des gens en général qu'il aurait
pas forcément fait à sortir à faire et
c'est donc c'est bien ça
c'est un signal aussi pour les jeunes
chercheurs 0 bosch que je peux faire
aussi la vulgarisation à côté exhorté
ses c'est vraiment génial je suis très
content de l'apprendre c'est un grand
grand truc qui est en angleterre ça
faisait déjà quelques temps que je
voyais ça et notamment il ya les bourses
marie curie en europe
eux ça fait je crois 5 6 ans qu'il ya
déjà un chapitre là dessus
et donc ça c'est génial alors ce qui est
ce qui est marrant c'est que dans mon
ancien la bo de post doc généralement
c'était tout le monde disait qu'il
allait faire des présentations paille
900 c'était moi du coup qui rédigeait
tous les tous les chapitres toutes les
bourses marie curie de tout ce qui
passait dans la bo parce que parce
qu'effectivement c'était oui on va faire
pinto cnc de cet art ils ont tous fait
d'ailleurs basile et des toc payne of
times et c'est bien vu voilà donc ce qui
est cool c'est qu'on arrive à un moment
où effectivement maintenant en plus ça a
toujours été plus ou moins dans la
mission du chercheur la valorisation
donc on dit valorisation mais c'est
vraiment aussi vers le public
mais là il ya tout un mouvement qui dit
qu'enfin tout un mouvement qui force un
peu qui pousse les chercheurs à
valoriser vulgariser à partager avec le
public parce qu'on se rend compte que il
ya beaucoup de financements qui sont
quand même deux qui viennent de l'argent
public
au final et entre
l'accès aux publications qui est
généralement payant le manque de
vulgarisation et c'est en fait on se
rend compte que m'a souvent le les gens
n'avaient pas accès à la science qui
paient finalement avec leurs impôts quoi
et puis il ya aussi le bus l'effort de
vulgarisation qui puisque bon même s'il
avait accès aux articles de recherche
passé combien de gens iraient les
articles en maths
non pas vraiment mais effectivement
maintenant il ya effort de vulgarisation
et puis c'est devenu sympa c'est devenu
il ya ya ya pleins pleins d'initiatives
il ya il ya des vidéos bah voila tu le
sais très bien il ya des vidéos sur
youtube donc ça ça rentre dans le
quotidien des gens c'est génial il ya
deux podcasts
il ya deux bouquins des bouquins de
vulgarisation de plus en plus sympa il y
en a de plus en plus sûr de plus en plus
de sujets il ya des blogs il ya twitter
avec des comptes s'il en direct du labo
la biolabo etc qui permettent à des
chercheurs de discuter du coup de
prendre les manettes des comptes il ya
tous les événements du gard isation
style ma thèse en 180 secondes payne 900
enfin voilà il ya tellement de trucs
c'est génial en fait et on est dans un
gros mouvement où ça voilà ça continue
il y en a de plus en plus c'est c'est
juste génial
ainsi comparé à 2013 on a fait un bout
de chemin assez énorme mais complètement
complètement et du coup c'est top parce
qu'en fait en terme de timing on est
arrivé vraiment au bon moment avec
patience et
et c'est chouette et voilà on participe
notamment aussi à cette expansion est
et je pense que c'est ça qui fait que
chaque année donc on a commencé avec
1000 personnes et l'année dernière il y
avait douze mille en français tu vas en
ce1 en cinq ans et la croissance a du
coup en cinq ans donc chaque année vous
avez gagné à chaque fois quelques
milliers de particules d'origine
ouais on a quasi doublé donc on a
commencé on a fait mille deux mille cinq
cent mille cinq dix mille
après on a commencé à atteindre un
plateau parce qu'il ya un moment ou pas
voilà tu peux pas non plus continuer sa
croissance
l'année dernière c'était 12000 là je
pense que cette année on va arriver
autour de 14 15 mille ouais ouais en
termes de ville aussi c'est énorme tu
vois on est en gros on a passé on est
passé de trois à huit à vingt à trente
quatre à quarante et une et l'a54 ok bah
c'est sûr génial c'est ça grossit et ça
va être un sol ouais alors à
l'international alors là c'est plus un
band ci parce que ça dépend des c'était
compliqué jusque là on n'avait pas
quelqu'un du coup c'est moi qui ai pris
cette fonction là mais qui gérait tous
les pays qui les aidaient etc
donc on essayait tous un petit peu
d'aider les nouveaux pays mais ce n'est
pas forcément très facile mais en gros
on a commencé donc juste en angleterre
et il ya eu je crois que 2014 on était
six après on a été dix tous quelque
chose comme ça l'année dernière on était
21 et c'était donc en gros on est passé
de
de 10 à 21 donc 2017 on était 10 j'ai
pris mes fonctions j'ai rajouté ont ce
pays boum
bah allez france à ce que j'avais ça
faisait tellement des années que j'avais
envie de le faire que voilà j'ai dit
allez cette année c'est la folie là
cette année on n'a augmenté que de 3
pays mais en fait il ya plein plein de
pays qui ont eu des nouveaux directeurs
donc du coup là ça demande énormément de
travail aussi dans le sens où les pays
exige déjà mais du coup les directeurs
sont complètement nouveau et et ont pas
forcément en main comment gérer un pays
entier quoi surtout ce quelque chose
c'est que quand tu commences un nouveau
pays tweetie va ta vitesse tu vois tu
dis bon je vais commencer avec peut-être
une ville où deux villes enfin tu
décides du nombre de villes mais
typiquement la l'espagne il ya les
anciens directeurs qui sont partis il ya
trois nouveaux co directeur qui s'y sont
lancés
ils ont 60 je crois qu'ils ont 79 ville
ou proche de 80 ça change 75 villes je
crois que 74 ans donc tu imagines tu
arrives tu sais pas comment gérer tout
un pays tu sais comment ça se passe par
900 mhz et a jamais géré tout le pays et
tu dois commencer avec 75 villes quoi
silva non mais voilà donc du coup c'est
hyper chaud donc souvent ce qui se passe
c'est que les nouveaux directeurs limite
pour eux c'est encore plus chaud que
pour les les tout nouveaux directeurs
dans les nouveaux pays où là il commence
vraiment à leur échelle tu vois on va de
l'épicé des trucs de malade on va du
brésil qui a 90 villes avec 44 mille
personnes adp comme le paraguay où il y
avait trois villes mais il y avait un
événement par ville donc en tout trois
événements sur trois soirs tu vas et là
faut s'adapter par rapport à la taille
du pays par rapport aux aux habitudes du
pays en termes de communication sur les
réseaux sociaux les lois aussi tu vois
dans chaque pays a sa propre entité
organisation paille 900 donc on n'est
pas forcément une asso ce pour tout le
monde on a une absence en france mais
dans tous les pays c'est pas forcément
le même statut enfin bon bref tu vas y a
tellement tellement de trucs à gérer que
du coup c'est vrai que parfois c'est
vraiment un gros gros casse-tête mais
c'est hyper c'est un gros challenge
parce que chaque pays est différent donc
donc c'est chouette il ya énormément de
directeur france est aussi ce qui me
plaît pas mal géré des directeurs
français dans les pays étrangers ouais
ouais ouais ok c'est c'est pas mal ça
sent la patte elodie ouais on sent au
sort le petit réseau tissé métisse genre
la suède
typiquement cd directrice française
singapour
c'est fantastique c'est c'est une
ancienne intervenante de paris qui est
parti en pause de quinze singapour etc a
lancé le truc excellent un des co
directeurs espagnols
c'est celui qui a aidé à lancer payne 2
cents à bordeaux et après il est parti
en espagne donc les quelques premiers
mois à bordeaux c'est lui qui a aidé a
pris les partis en espagne et il a aidé
par 900 en espagne il était coordinateur
barcelone et maintenant il est co
directeur
tu vois enfin ça c'est drôle tu vois la
mafia française
j'aime bien connu pour ça que pour vivre
mais voilà c'est rigolo tu sais quand je
sors je vous parle aux fondateurs jeu
j'ai des directeurs sont là c'est encore
des français ah non c'est pas possible
mamie écoute et puis on a un échange
aussi c'est ça qui est chouette c'est
que maintenant il ya donc comme souvent
les équipes cd des chercheurs ou des
chercheuses on a souvent des gens qui
partent en pause ou qui reviennent de
post doc et tout est donc on s'échange
tu sais on dit aïe à intel qui vient de
partir est ce que tu as besoin de
quelqu'un dans telle ville et machins et
nous si on fait vraiment les les
échanges entre les villes et tout c'est
assez cool c'est c'est assez sympa
cluzel avoir une communauté punk rock
salsa au sein de la recherche aussi
tenir à mes sens rôle et la recherche
mais c'est un truc de fou c'est énorme
c'est quand je quand je fais des
journées doctorants même que je
rencontre des chercheurs et tout alors
avant pâques 200 me disait paito voilà
qu'est ce que c'est maintenant c'est je
rencontre les gens c'est forcément ils
en ont soit ils ont des intervenants qui
l'on fait soit ils ont intervenu sur le
truc soit il songe à aller enfin cesser
c'est devenu énorme quoi et le truc
c'est que donc il ya mon pauvre homme
qui vit qui vit pas une preuve ça y est
ça on peut dire et lui typiquement il
s'est rendu compte de la grandeur du
truc
là c'était quand c'était cet hiver je
crois il est parti à hong kong
donc on n'a pas pas 900 à hong kong dont
turenne normalement il aurait dû être
peinard j'étais pas là pour brasser les
oreilles j'étais pas là pour lui brasser
les oreilles à propos de payne 200 dons
qu'il aurait dû il aurait dû être
peinard tranquille et il avait son petit
t-shirt painters de l'année dernière et
tout machin il rentre dans un dans un
ascenseur blindé de gens et là tu as une
nana qu'ils regardent et qui lui dit où
est ce que tu as eu ton t-shirt et là il
lui répond il lui dit bah en fait c'est
pas un top 5 ce machin à lui dit non
mais je t'arrête tout de suite je
connais paito signs je suis australienne
donc à hong kong
une australienne elle dit je suis fan du
festival mais je me demandais juste tout
avait eu ton tee shirt il élit dibaba
partenaires c'est voilà c'est la
directrice internationale du combat
c'est pas de la france et dit qu elle
était trop fans etc
mais c'est énorme il m'appelle et me dit
alors on est à hong kong j'ai rencontré
une australienne qui est fan du type de
panne sofiane s'est elle a vu le t-shirt
français et elle m'a arrêté dans
l'ascenseur à cause de mon t-shirt
français il me dit vous êtes juste une
énorme mafia set partout c'est pas
possible
ouais c'est la classe non mais c'était
génial setubal et l'année dernière ont
tous dans le monde
on a eu 100 ans à peu près 120
cent vingt mille participants c'est donc
120 milles c'est les gens qui sont venus
à nos événements
après on a à peu près 3000 en équipe on
doit être entre 2500 et 3000 personnes
et en chercheur l'année dernière
donc scientifiques ont participé je
dirais qu'on est entre quatre et cinq
mille ans tous dans le monde ok
intervenants ouais intervenants ok c'est
cool et du coup ça ce professionnel du
coutach mart était employée de 26 ans
alors non je suis je suis free lance
donc en gros je suis pas je suis pas
salarié de paille 900
angleterre c'est eux qui me paye pour
développer le festival ce sont les
fondateurs et qui gère du coup
l'international mais en gros je suis
freelens donc ça fait partie tu vois de
mes clients mais je fais d'autres choses
à côté je fais pas que pines et la
france je suis toujours bénévole je
tiens à le dire parce que parfois les
équipes pensent que tu vois les deux
euros qu'on paye pour les les soirées
c'est avec ça que je me paye ou je sais
pas quoi
non parce que très clairement je serai
je serais très très peu payés tu vois et
puis en plus moi je remets tout l'argent
qu'on reçoit du festival dans le
festival dans les goodies dans le site
web dans et c'est ok mais du coup je
pense qu'il y aura un besoin de se
professionnaliser davantage alors je
pense que typiquement tu vois là le job
que je fais en tant que directrice
internationale
clairement on en avait besoin parce que
il ya tellement besoin de dead sur tous
les pays avec tous les créneaux horaires
différents que s'il n'y avait pas ça
effectivement on pourrait pas se
développer donc
donc oui a besoin après typiquement en
termes de modèle on pourrait pas avoir
100% des équipes qui sont payés ou alors
on aurait un mini mini festival tu vois
là on est dans 54 villes on a à peu près
entre 400 et 500 personnes en france
en tout cas et personne n'est payé moi
non plus donc après l'étape d'après
c'est éventuellement peut-être mois de
freelance et dessus un peu aussi c'est à
dire avoir plus de sponsors et pouvoir
passer plus de temps du coup dessus mais
tu vois ça sera jamais du plein temps
mais voilà après ce qui est bien c'est
qu'en termes de professionnalisme
il ya quand même ça c'est à dire que ça
fait ça va faire sept ans attend ça fait
six ans plus de six ans que du coup je
gère paito signs donc en terme
d'expérience tu vois j'ai ça va je gère
j'ai vu plein de pays se lançait donc
j'ai un peu vu tous les tous les cas de
figure possibles et imaginables tu vois
dans tous les continents
on a on est vraiment partout partout
donc donc du coup au niveau
professionnalisme c'est là c'est plus au
niveau argent ou là effectivement
faudrait qu'on trouve notamment pour le
développement international faudrait
qu'on ait des sponsors tu vois même des
boîtes qui auraient envie de sponsoriser
le développement de certains pays et qui
financerait ça par exemple mais parce
que si j'imagine pour les directeurs des
différents pays c'est facile ça change
d'une année à l'autre
ça s'est un peu compliqué que celui des
3100 plus oui alors après le truc c'est
que ce qu'on dit toujours au directeur
sait s'ils peuvent trouver des moyens de
financer donc soit avec la vente des
tickets nous en france et 2 euros mais
tu vois en angleterre ces quatre livres
par ticket par exemple donc s'il ya des
pays où ça pose pas de problème de faire
ça un peu plus cher ou s'il trouve des
sponsors ou des mêmes des financements
des bourses des choses comme ça en fait
on arrête personne si jamais il ya des
directeurs de main qui sont en mi temps
ou en plein temps sur penneteau scène
sinon on est super heureux
on leur conseille même parfois d'essayer
mais généralement le festival ce qu'on a
ce qu'on a envie de faire c'est que ce
soit par tous et du coup voilà on essaye
de faire en sorte de favoriser plus le
développement du festival versus de se
payer tu vois les premières années même
je t'avoue que c'est moi qu'avancer
l'argent pour le festival tu vois j'ai
avancé pour les goodies pour pour tous
les tous les frais et en gros je
croisais les doigts que festival marché
que que les gens achètent des tickets
parce que sinon c'était mes vacances
enfin le plus même que mes vacances
calais partir en fumée quoi donc voila
quand arrive à un point
tu vois là ça fait ça à faire la 6éme
édition c'est la quatrième fois que j'ai
rien à avancer ça fait quand même super
plaisir le festival tourne tout seul
voilà et donc moi ce que j'ai envie
d'avoir c'est un festival qui tourne
donc je vais je vais préférant enfin tu
vois je vais je vais préférer faire en
sorte que le festival tourne que y ait
de l'argent que j'ai rien n'a avancé que
tout se passe bien et puis bah si je
peux me payer ce sera un bonus un jour
si si j'arrive à avoir des sponsors un
peu plus gros ou tu vois des oudairies
des demandes de financement et des trucs
comme ça mais c'est pas ouais il y en a
qui sont payés n'ont pas alors il y en a
qui sont payés dans le monde y en a que
deux qui sont payés c'est l'angleterre
les deux directeurs anglais après il y a
donc ils sont payés par penneteau ksikes
anglet angle angleterre après dans le
reste du monde généralement jeu
pas que je sache par contre après tu as
des gens qui sont payés c'est à dire
qu'ils font qui rendent pas une top 100
dans leurs missions de boulot
typiquement la directrice de la nouvelle
zélande
lcl bosse sur la valorisation dans un
grand institut et c est donc à la
rentrée par une toxine dans sa mission
et donc elle n'est pas payée par
penneteau cents mais faire développé par
intel scène ça fait partie de ses
missions elle donc du coup ça peux tu
vois ça peut ça peut marcher comme ça
aussi c'est à dire qu'elle fait pas
forcément ça le soir et le week-end le
salon elle peut très bien faire ça
pendant ces journées de boulot et puis
et puis du coup voilà elle n'est pas
payée par penneteau cents mais sont en
panne de cnce est rémunérée d'une autre
façon pareil pour iliad et ya certes un
coordinateur de villes en france qui ont
des missions doctorale donc ça veut dire
qu'ils sont payés par les écoles
doctorales ou en gros par je sais plus
exactement quels mécanismes csn mais
qu'on des missions rémunérées pour
travailler sur des trucs et il y en a
une notamment à strasbourg qui est en
mission doctorat sur paint of sound
ok donc ça veut dire que ça fait partie
de sa mission doctorale tu vois donc ça
c'est cool je crois qu'elle est payée
par un organisme de de culture
scientifique et
et donc en gros sont en panne au cnc
rémunérés mais c'est pas ces papas et au
cndd qui paye ça peut être un modèle
intéressant aussi tu vois ce qu'elle des
choses que je pense que pinto ce fait
fait pas très bien encore oui clairement
il ya un truc sur lequel on pourrait
vraiment vraiment s'améliorer et que
j'essaie de pousser mais c'est dur
sachant qu' il ya enfin voilà les
équipes sont déjà super occupé à
organiser le truc le festival s'est
formé les les intervenants parce que
c'est bien de mettre des intervenants
devant le public mais ça serait bien si
il en tirait aussi une formation des
conseils etc
alors on a déjà un truc on a un document
qu'il ordonne en gros les grands lignes
sur les trucs à faire les trucs à éviter
etc
donc on l'est on les laisse pas
complètement tu vois se débrouiller sans
rien et tout l'année dernière j'ai
commencé à faire des espèces de petites
de petites classes payne 100 mini classe
tu vois genre soirée de deux trois
heures avant le festival où ils
pouvaient se rencontrer on pouvait
discuter de comment comment vulgariser
leurs recherches comment tu vois comment
être plus engageant avec le public et c
est ça avait plutôt bien marché donc je
pense que ça peut être un truc sur
lesquelles on pourrait travailler et tu
vois je les lancer en france mais des
autres pays n'ont pas forcément fait ça
pourrait être quelque chose sur lequel
on travaille je pense qu'il ya dix ans
et d'expertisé jusqu'au moto toi t'es tu
es beaucoup de tentations du coûteux
d'acheter une certaine expertise mais
bah alors ce qu'on peut faire c'est tu
vois moi je pourrais déjà formés en fait
préparer des présentations et former
éventuellement aller personne à le faire
dans les autres pays dans les autres
villes etc
et puis souvent quand même on est des
gens qui organisent pas 900 de plus en
plus on a des gens qui font la
communication scientifique à côté qui
organise mind saison qui serait super
bon de toute façon à former les gens
nous accueillent donc donc il y aurait
mais effectivement c'est le truc je
pense sur lequel il faut qu'on travaille
un peu parce qu'en terme de regard on
gère bien
des bénévoles qui sont surmotivés qui
trouvent des soirées top qui trouvent
des idées de soirée top qui organise
bien ça et c'est donc je pense que c'est
vraiment le truc sur lequel tout le
monde y gagnerait déjà les intervenants
parce que ça leur donnerait une petite
formation en plus ce qui leur ferait du
bien à certains je pense et puis nous on
y gagne en qualité aussi c'est à dire
que plus on forme nos intervenants plus
on est sûr de la qualité qu'on aura en
soirée quoi les bénévoles c'est ce sont
des étudiants on a de tout on a
alors avant s'étaient majoritairement
des scientifiques des étudiants en thèse
des doctorants ou des ou des post
doctorants ou même des chercheurs déjà
établis de plus en plus on a des
journalistes scientifiques des gens qui
font de la communication de la culture
scientifique comme boulot qui du coup
prennent le truc dedans tu vois les deux
les deux directeurs belle belge par
exemple eux ils sont pas scientifiques
du tout sont juste à fond sur la science
donc voilà de plus en plus en fait plus
ça se développe et plus ça s'ouvre à
d'autres gens qui sont juste passionné
par la science et c'est pas mal parce
que quand organise des soirées et que tu
es scientifique et que tu penses à
quelqu'un qui sera un bon intervenant
parfois c'est en intervenant qui est un
peu trop un peu trop jargon un peu trop
un peu trop la tête dans la science et
du coup ces gens-là eux quand ils
trouvent qu'un intervenant est bon les
gens qui font pas forcément de la
science qui sont pas scientifiques c'est
que générallement cette personne-là en
vulgarisation les a touchés donc
effectivement elle est bonne donc
donc voilà il ya de tout en fait il ya
en ce qu'il ya c'est que nous on ne
refuse personne ici un intervenant veut
intervenir
voilà donc et on les aide et c'est
pareil dans les équipes on dit jamais à
banon faut être scientifique pour
organiser paito sainz s'est il faut
juste être motivés donc partiront ou tu
as envie de le faire ou tu trouves tu
trouve le concept couler tu as envie de
le répliquer le développer dans ton dans
ta ville dans ton barétous nous il n'y a
aucun souci
surtout que il ya énormément de doc de
suivi et tous pour apprendre à bien
faire des soirées payne de seine sur ok
et coco fait pour trouver les des
interviews con pourquoi aller chercher
les arrivées les chercheurs alors la
pêche aux chercheurs il ya deux façons
la toute première celle qu'on a fait
depuis le début c'est les équipes donc
t'as plein de division des équipes donc
généralement telle équipe nationale qui
gère un peu tout talent et coordinateur
de région qui eux gèrent plusieurs
plusieurs villes talent et coordinateur
de ville qui managent plusieurs
plusieurs équipes dans la ville état les
managers des votes donc eu généralement
c'est vraiment les hommes
ghani thater donc ils vont trouver un
bar et des intervenants pour trois soirs
donc là ils partent à la chasse des
intervenants dont qu'ils réfléchissent à
des thèmes qui les intéressent à des
intervenants locaux bien sûr toujours
généralement en majorité ces des
intervenants locaux donc qui est ce
qu'il ya dans les universités les
instituts autour etc et qui les
contactent et il ya eu de deuxième
technique de chasse à l'intervenant qui
qu'on a commencé depuis deux trois ans
je crois c'est un formulaire un appel en
fait sur les réseaux sociaux un appel
intervention tout simplement parce que
avant au tout début on l'avait pas fait
et que bas sur les réseaux sociaux je
crois que c'était en 2016 du coup j'ai
eu des remarques de gens qui m'ont dit
oh mais j'aurais bien participer mais
j'ai pas vu passer d'appels et là je me
suis dit bah ouais c'est normal t'as pas
vu passer d'appel parce que il y en a
pas eu
et du coup je me suis dit vas peut-être
qu'au final ça serait pas mal d'avoir un
appel à un intervenant ou du coup les
gens qui seraient hors de portée des
équipes parce que juste les équipes qui
pense pas ou les équipes les connaissent
pas tout simplement leur donner une
chance de faire de faire ça donc
maintenant vraiment il ya les deux y
aller de façon trop et est ce que
j'avais des mines de plus en plus de
liens avec des institutions comme les
nerfs ou le cnrs ou alors le cnrs
typiquement on est bon on est partenaire
depuis l'année dernière
tout simplement parce que on avait déjà
des fins quasiment pas la moitié de nos
chercheurs nos intervenants mais on a
bien fait pas un tiers de nos
intervenants qui étaient du cnrs
donc on est allé les voir leur disant
bon comment vous dire on utilise déjà
que ce intervenants donc si on pouvait
partenaires mettre le logo pour eux
c'est quand même mieux d'avoir le bon
logo
de pouvoir l'afficher de leur avoir
demandé leur permission et puis du coup
ça fait ça fait deux choses chouette
c'est que on peut les équipes peuvent
aller voir les délégations régionales
qui peuvent avoir des idées
d'intervenants qui viennent d'écrire un
bouquin qui viennent d'écrire un article
intéressant et c'est peut-être des
intervenants qui sont un petit peu plus
compliqué à avoir tu vois des gens un
peu trop busy que si on envoyait juste
un mail en tant que équipe organisatrice
pas une 100 répondrait jamais mais par
contre s'il cnrs leur demande de faire
un penneteau scène cela très clairement
ça sera plus facile
donc du coup ça va être bien et puis
nous en échange aussi on fait des
soirées cnrs par exemple il ya eu la
journée de la mort le 6 février pour
l'année de la chimie ou là on a organisé
trois soirées par 900 avec le cnrs donc
du coup tu vois c'est donnant donnant on
concède parce que voilà pour eux au
final c'est bien d'avoir d'avoir leurs
chercheurs qui parlent à peine 100 c'est
du coup autant autant nous donner des
noms et puis et puis nous ça nous aide
s'il ya des noms de gens qui connaissent
qui sont déjà bien en vulgarisation pas
autant les utiliser quoi ça se passe
bien alors là c'est impressionnant donc
c'est nage génial l'inserm
malheureusement beaucoup moins bien
à cause de notre relation à l'alcool
voilà même si on prône absolument pas là
la consommation et que nos soirées payne
100 sont quand même très calme au grand
dam des bars parfois qui trouvent qu'on
consomme pas assez mais voilà les
l'inserm en tout cas nous aime un petit
peu moins et après les autres il faut
que j'aille il faut que j'aille à la
pêche tout ce qui est ca et compagnie il
faut il faut que j'aille à la pêche que
je discute avec eux mais d'une façon
générale en local les universités sont
sont super partenaires sont super
partante donc si vous allez tu vas sur
les pages des villes ta généralement les
logos des universités les logos des
localités tu vois des villes parfois des
communes et enfin de plein plein de
choses donc en fait chaque année au
rallye de plus en plus de monde avec
nous donc
donc c'est chouette il ya un ministère
aussi on était partenaire pour la fête
de la science
donc donc voilà en fait tout va bien en
termes de partenaires
c'est juste que parfois pour que ce soit
valide officiellement tu vois il
faudrait aller voir les instituts leur
demande et nationalement si on peut
utiliser leur logo et tout ça tout ça
mais
mais d'une façon générale on a on a
quand même énormément de partenaires
institutionnels derrière nous et vous
quand tu vois le futur de paris tote
signs vous allez continuer à conquérir
le monde
exactement en fait le futur moi je le
vois donc conquérir le monde mais avec
une idée en tête c'est que j'aimerais
vraiment bien qu'on aille dans les pays
plus compliqué tu vas commencer par
exemple a colonisé l'afrique c'est plus
qu'ailleurs et corée du nord ouais bon
là là ça serait encore plus compliqué
mais pour d'autres raisons mais
le nom georges genre l'afrique tu vas
des pays où vraiment quand je vois par
exemple le paraguay costa rica les
retours où ils nous disent mais en fait
les gens sont super heureux d'avoir
penneteau sense parce que en france on a
de la chance on a pleins d'initiatives
de culture scientifique mais il ya des
pays où il n'ya pas grand chose voire
rien du tout et du coup quand il ya ça
les gens vraiment prennent ça comme
comme comme un truc génial qui leur
permet de rencontrer des chercheurs et
d'avoir accès à la science et du coup
j'ai vraiment envie de de développer ça
tu vois dans des pays d'afrique dans du
pays du moyen-orient où ça peut être
aussi un petit peu plus compliqué
vraiment partout et l'idée de conquérir
le monde c'est pas juste d'être super
mégalo et d'être partout c'est vraiment
de se dire il faut que tout le monde ait
accès à la science ouais tu vois moi tue
pas être mégalo en europe mais non voilà
mêmes même en france tu vois là l'idée
d'être partout au départ on a bien sûr
commencé dans les grandes villes etc
mais là typiquement on commence à aller
dans des villes un petit peu plus petit
en ardèche typiquement
tu vois c'est pas des villes c'est
plutôt des villages et ça c'est génial
j'adore je suis super contente et plus
on va développer sa et mieux ce sera
parce que ces endroits là au final ont
aussi beaucoup moins de possibilités de
d'avoir des événements de culture
scientifique tu vois à paris on est on
en a tout le temps partout
si on veut franchement chaque soir on
peut faire un événement de culture
scientifique alors que baho fin fond de
l'ardèche pas forcément donc je trouve
que ces endroits là sont vraiment hyper
important à conquérir est vraiment pour
une une idée de partager la science est
de faire en sorte que tout le monde ait
accès à la science et que ce soit
vraiment pas un truc de grandes villes
ou un truc de pays riches quoi surtout
que meiway c'est hyper important il ya
des pays il ya des pays qui font de la
recherche en afrique il ya la recherche
et c'est dommage que ce soit pas plus
mise en lumière et que et que la
population ait pas plus accès à ça tu
vois mais c'est vrai que c'est plus
compliqué ça va être des pays où ça va
demander plus de temps donc c'est pas
forcément les pays sur lesquels on sait
on s'est jeté s'est pas non plus les
pays sur lesquels on a énormément de
gens qui proposent de le faire au tout
début donc tu vas fin ça va être plus
compliqué mais c'est vrai que moi c'est
mon vrai but c'est ce à quoi s'est c'est
bien de se développer dans des pays dans
des pays un peu riches ou dans des pays
bien développé
mais le jour où on sera vraiment dans
des pays plus plus difficile plus
difficiles d'accès où la science est
vraiment le dernier des soucis de la
plupart des habitants et ça deviendra
peut-être tu vas quelque chose avec
lesquels ils seront un peu plus familier
franchement là je serai heureuse là je
considérais que mon boulot il est fait
tu vois tu étais déjà fait pas mal mais
ouais mais tu vas enfin c'est toujours
c'est toujours se dire ouais c'est bien
mais même amérique du sud tu vois on
n'est pas dans tant de pays ça j'ai
vraiment envie que cet envoi tes fautes
ont voté lieutenant français un peu pas
exactement où j'en vois la mafia
française
copé ailleurs mais mais c'est ça tu vas
vraiment ce qui me tient hyper à coeur
voilà s'est développée d'avoir un
développement comme ça savoir à nos sacs
jetés calmer la rue
et quand s'est passée dans le futur la
vulgarisation scientifique plus
largement
alors est ce que tu peux redéfinir un
petit peu trop puisque ces perles argent
fait ouais bah tu penses que ça va
continuer à grossir parce que là ça
quand même malgré aussi je pense qu'on a
sur sa way ce que j'aimerais c'est que
chaque projet soit vulgarisé tu vois
ouais typiquement il y avait un truc
dont on avait parlé à un moment donc à
londres j'étais dans souvent dans des
événements de penzance donc le mouvement
qui se dit que on devrait pas payer pour
des articles scientifiques surtout des
articles scientifiques
qui sont payés un deuil pardon des des
projets scientifiques qui sont payés
avec l'argent public ça donc il ya le
plan s notamment en europe
je sais pas ça me parle alors le plan s
en europe alors je suis pas super
spécialisés mais je peux te le définir
rapidement
c'est en gros un plan qui dit qui dit
qu' à partir de 2020 les travaux qui
auront été financés par l'argent public
devront être publiés dans des revues
open access ok donc ça à l'échelle de
toute l'europe
ouais à l'échelle de toute l'europe donc
c'est quand même chaud parce que 2020
2020 c'est demain et c'est pas dans la
nature nécessairement de la recherche de
publier dans ce genre de revues ou en
tout cas d'avoir des revues gratuite
donc ça va changer pas mal de trucs mais
du coup il ya tout un mouvement la clé
en route pour faire en sorte que toute
la science ou en tout cas la science
payés par l'argent public soit
accessible et donc effectivement c'est
bien de se dire que monsieur tout le
monde pourra aller regarder ce qui se
passe sur les articles scientifiques
mais moi je pense que le truc hyper
important c'est de faire en sorte que
tous les projets soit vulgarisé parce
que c'est c'est le pire qui puisse se
passer c'est de lire un article
scientifique de rien comprendre
et après d'aller cracher sur internet
des trucs qui veulent rien dire et c est
donc du coup il y avait eu une
discussion pas mal sûr est ce que ça ne
serait pas une bonne idée pour les
journaux en open access d'avoir un
abstract pour le grand public du coup tu
vois si tu es si t'es pas du tout
familier avec la science mais que tu
tombe sur un article scientifique y aura
quand même un abstract un morceau
d'articles donc un résumé de l'article
qui sera fait pour toi et qui sera fait
pour que tu comprennes et que du coup tu
puisse partager l'article
en ayant compris de quoi ça parle ouais
ça serait pas mal
est ce que j'ai non mais dis ce que j'ai
à dire que j'ai découvert récemment que
j'étais une conférence tripoli your way
ont sorti récemment et j'ai découvert en
fait que
du coup ceux qui organisent cette
conférence c'est aussi un magazine et il
voulait justement le pays venait de
lancer un projet de magazine sur lie à
vulgariser j'ai réparé par tripoli
du coup par des chercheurs web de m donc
ça ça grossit petit à petit sur deux
choses ça grossit et c'est top
et du coup pour moi vraiment l'avenir de
la vulgarisation c'est que tous les
projets soit vulgarisé d'une façon ou
d'une autre et que tout le monde puisse
avoir accès à tous les projets de
recherche ou en tout cas tous les
projets de recherche financés par de
l'argent public donc tu vois cette
histoire de de vulgariser tous les
articles ça peut être une bonne chose
mais mais voilà pour moi la
vulgarisation c'est vraiment ça doit
devenir une étape aussi importante que
la publication pour les chercheurs et du
coup est ce que tu penses que c'est aux
chercheurs de vulgariser alors je pense
qu'il ya un peu de tout ce qu'ils ont
envie de le faire je pense qu'on devrait
pas les empêcher
il ya aussi les médiateurs donc des gens
enfin pour qui c'est le travail de faire
ça et je trouve qu'ils sont hyper
importants et du coup c'est important
qu'il travaille en équipe avec les
chercheurs et que surtout ils voient pas
les chercheurs qui vulgarise comme comme
une compétition
tu vois mais ce que je disais souvent en
fait quand tu es chercheurs tu vois tu
sais c'est un peu comme si tu étais
pâtissier et que tu passais je sais pas
moi une journée entière à faire un
superbe gâteau tu vois genre tu
travailles de sutton gâteau il est beau
il est censé être bon et tout est en
fait si tu fais pas la vulgarisation toi
même c'est comme si tu donnais le gâteau
à quelqu'un pour que cette personne la
phase goûter à des gens etc en fait
après on disait oui ils ont bien aimé
mais que tu voyais pas les réactions des
gens tuent leur faisait pas goûté ton
gâteau toi même et je trouve que quand
tu es chercheurs et où chercheuse et que
tu t'expliques tes recherches que tu
l'aies vulgarise et que tu vas notamment
live ou quoi et que tu vois la réaction
des gens tu sais la petite étincelle de
leurs yeux qui se dit ouais j'ai compris
un truc qui avait l'air super compliqué
de base et j'ai réussi à le comprendre
c'est juste génial en fait pour moi
c'est de la drogue
enfin je trouve ça fantastique de voir
la réaction du public
ça c'est un chercheur c'est j'adore je
marche vraiment à ça et donc je trouve
qu'ils doivent faire de la vulgarisation
mais c'est pareil il devrait pas en
faire si c'est pas un truc qu'ils ont
envie de faire après il serait qu'il y à
des domaines qui sont plus difficiles à
vulgariser les quais d'autres exact il
ya des domaines mais après je dis
toujours aussi qu' il n'y a rien qui est
pas vulgarise abl c'est juste ça va
demander plus ou moins de temps c'est
sûr que tu fais de la physique théorique
sur un truc ça peut être super compliqué
alors que typiquement moi qui travaille
sur l'épilepsie tu vois c'était plutôt
facile de vulgariser ouais je le pense
toujours à félicien capable de
m'expliquer théorie quantique des champs
voilà mais effectivement tu vois c'est
je pense que il faut pas faire de
généralités dire les chercheurs
devraient pas vulgariser ou dire tout le
monde de tous les chercheurs devraient
vulgariser je pense que tous les projets
devraient avoir un côté de vulgarisation
tu vois un composant du gard isation
c'est à dire tu devrais pouvoir avoir
accès à tous les projets de recherche
vulgariser mais après est-ce que c'est
le chercheur qui est capable de le faire
qui a le temps de le faire ou est ce que
c'est je sais pas moi des organismes
spéciaux qui vont vulgariser ça tu vois
que ce soit par des des sites web que ce
soit de la formation tu vas de
présentation je sais pas ça peut être un
peu plein de choses ça peut être des
médiateurs aussi qui viennent et qui
participe avec le chercheur mais je
trouve que en tout cas tous les projets
devraient avoir cette composante là et
pour moi vraiment c'est l'avenir tout ça
que j'attends moi ici aviva this way
donc bon on est d'accord il s'inscrit
puisse dire ça mais surtout que en fait
ce qui me fait mal au coeur c'est qu'on
voit que les financements de la
recherche s'arrête s'est réduit
généralement et quand s'est réduit la
plupart des gens s'en foutent
pourquoi parce que au final c'est pas
des choses qui les touchent
c'est pas le chômage directement ça nous
touche tous qui est allocation impôts
tout ça on est touché et c est en fait
la science ne se rend pas compte qu'on
est touché parce que c'est quelque chose
qui fait partie de nos vies c'est
quelque chose qui nous affectent
complètement que ce soit la médecine
quand on est malade
que ce soit la technique là là enfin la
technologie un peu tout tu vois on est
vraiment hyper affecté par par la
recherche et ce qui se passe et du coup
je trouve que en fait si jamais on
pouvait vulgariser beaucoup plus ça
permettrait aussi au public d'être plus
consciente de ce qui se passe comme
recherche et de voir que la rechercher
partout et de prendre conscience au fait
de tout ce qui se passe et de voir
l'importance de ça et ça aiderait
peut-être c'est une espèce de boucle
vertueuse de se dire peut-être que ils
voteront pour des peut-être des partis
qui parle de la recherche ou peut-être
que de plus en plus si tu veux en
politique on parle de plus en plus de
financements de recherche et ça
prendrait une part importante là en fait
ce qui est fou c'est que la recherche
est hyper importante dans nos vies mais
mais on s'en soucie pas parce que quand
on dit bah ouais ya 300 millions qui ont
un budget de 300 millions de cas étaient
coupées en recherche
les gens se disent bah c'est pas grave
on s'en fout ça sert à rien tu vois et
au final après ils vont être malade tu
as enfin c'est pas espérer mais mais tu
dis demain quelqu'un de ta famille où
toi tu as un cancer tu réussis à t'en
sortir ben ça c'est grâce grâce à la
recherche
et c'est pas forcément visible c'est à
dire que ben voilà c'est ont dit non
c'est les médecins bah ouais mais les
médecins ils n'ont pas inventé les
thérapies comme ça quoi ce petit coin
discussions des gens arrêtés à la pige
enix et même des trucs assez flou étudié
pas faux faux faux financer ce à quoi
exactement faut financer et puis parfois
faut accepter le fait que tu vas mettre
de l'argent sur la table ça risque de
coûter très cher ça est de prendre du
temps et puis bah après ça va pas
forcément être rentable tout de suite ou
être très rentable mais voilà c'est un
peu c'est un peu un coup de poker c'est
vrai que ça coûte de l'argent mais mais
cet argent il y en a besoin je pense
pour pour évoluer en tant que pays et
sociétés
après j'aurai aussi votre argument en
faveur de vulgarisation scientifique et
que je pense que ça rend heureux comme
je pense que les gens qui s'intéressent
à sa sont beaucoup plus joyeux que
qu'elle était intéressée à beaucoup de
sujets de politique est d'actualité
moyens mais exactement fin tu vois là
par exemple j'étais trop heureuse
aujourd'hui que
twitter soit noyé par les photos du trou
noir c'est un truc de fou c'est bien et
c'est chouette et puis c'est vrai ça
voilà on se dit voilà on vit une époque
qui est quand même génial à vivre et
c'est mieux que de voir que trump a
encore dit une énième âneries sur
twitter ou sur la télé et c est autre
chose j'avais oublié un argument encore
pour la vulgarisation et le fait que en
fait plus on aura de vulgarisation moins
il y aura de fait que nous
enfin en tout cas je l'espère et c'est
un peu ouais mon avis et puis mon espoir
on va dire c'est que souvent la
recherche et la science c'est très
compliqué d'accord tu tombes sur un
papier de recherche cdu baragouin
scientifique c'est compliqué et du coup
tu peut l'interpréter d'une façon ou
d'une autre
facilement plus il ya de vulgarisation
plus la façon d'interpréter les trucs ça
sera noir sur blanc et ça sera ce sera
une façon et et pas forcément d'une
autre et du coup ce qui circulera pluie
à d'un futur vulgariser qui circuleront
plus j'espère les faits qui nous sont
aussi réduire et les gens vont
s'habituer à la science à la façon dont
la science est fait et peut-être avoir
un peu plus l'esprit critique mais ça
c'est en mode gros bisounours tu vois
que la vulgarisation va battre les faits
que news je sais que ça c'est
probablement ça n'arrivera pas c'est à
peu près autant que malicorne commandé à
noël dernier
tu vois ça n'arrivera probablement
autant pas mais en tout cas ça peut je
pense ça peut permettre de réduire tout
ça mais c'est certain sens que je dis ce
que je pense qu'il ya un peu à un
préjugé assez souvent erronée de pas mal
de gens qui est que une fois que tu as
expliqué les choses la personne ne va
pas comprendre et accepter l'entrée
qu'alors que souvent on fait le genre de
truc c'est celle à répétition
en plus répétition venant de plusieurs
personnes c'est beaucoup plus efficace
que mêmes personnes qui répètent sans
cesse le même discours et du coup c'est
très important qu'ils aient plusieurs
vulgarisateur plusieurs vulgarisation du
même sujet sur différents angles et
ainsi de suite
exactement exactement mais je crois
qu'il y avait une étude alors je vais
pas dire de bêtises mais il me semble
qu'il ya une étude qui est qui et il ya
un article est paru qui te qui essayait
de voir si est ce que tu peux être
persuadé de quelque chose quand tu n'y
crois pas de base
tu vois et je crois que c'est très
difficile de faire changer les gens
d'opinions
donc voilà donc du coup l'idée c'est de
se dire faudrait que dès le début tu
vois des trucs comme les vaccins créé
l'autisme ça ça n'existe même pas comme
phrase tu vois mais effectivement cesse
et c'est trés bisounours et ça
n'arrivera probablement pas mais
mais voilà en tout cas se dire moyen
d'un faux compliqué plus plus ce sera
simple de comprendre la bonne façon de
comprendre le truc là c'est vrai que
même même en termes de journalisme tu
vois tu sais c'est parfois compliqué
quand tu effaces un scientifique qui
parle qui baragouine ces trucs en pas du
tout pas du tout vulgariser d'essayer de
tirer la bonne info de comprendre tu as
enfin c'est hyper dur et je pense que
quand un autre espoir que j'ai pour la
vulgarisation c'est que ce soit vraiment
dans la formation des chercheurs
ça commence ouais c'est c'est hyper
important et ça commence en test de plus
en plus met donc là ça veut dire qu'on a
une génération de chercheurs entre ce
qu'ont fait leurs thèses
il ya quelques années et ce qu'ont fait
leurs thèses il ya très longtemps tous
ces chercheurs la ont pas été formé donc
c'est compliqué mais tu vois il faut
juste parce que même si on fait pas des
événements de vulgarisation et que ça ne
vient pas ton dada tu vois de faire de
la vulgarisation en tant que chercheur
il ya un moment ça va être utile
ça va être ça va être utile et même
c'est ce que je vends toujours aux
chercheurs c'est de leur dire quand vous
faites des demandes de financement vous
avez un comité où un jury face à vous
les gens sont rarement exactement du
même domaine
typiquement tu vois tu trouve déjà en
neurosciences mais ça va pas être des
gens qui travaillent sur mon type
d'épilepsie par exemple ça aura été des
gens qui font de la neuro peut-être
alzheimer parkinson et tout mais du coup
faut savoir vendre son projet à
expliquer pourquoi c'est important
et puis parler parler de la science
derrière mais d'une façon que tout le
monde va comprendre tu vois même en tant
que chercheur la vulgarisation c'est
important parce que la vulgarisation
faut pas oublier que c'est pas seulement
vulgariser vers le public
vulgariser c'est juste mais ton
vocabulaire au niveau de la personne en
face et babar jallet j'avais prévu de
finir par te parler de ça mais en effet
je pense qu'il ya un énorme besoin de ce
que j'ai déjà vu le mot semi
vulgarisation quelque part une et deux
et heavy content quand je décris ma
propre revue les relations en fait c'est
pas forcément l'attention
de paris un très très grand public mais
déjà juste parler un public de
scientifiques ou de genre qui qui n'ont
pas forcément peur d'une équation de
malte et ça reste un niveau de
vulgarisation important parce que la
plupart des scientifiques par exemple ne
sont pas très à l'aise avec la théorie
des ensembles on va dire qu'elles sont
comme ça non mais moi déjà gagné ouais
carrément mois déjà je suis très très
mal à l'aise avec tout ce qui est
statpro bas tout ça en déjà donc là
d'attaqué face de toi qui est
scientifique et quand on lui disait oui
tu peux calculer les stats les machins
donc la sûreté data je devenais toute
blanche et et je me faisais tout petit
et je disparais ses soupes durant les jo
qui effectivement mal à celui de gary
station en fait je pense que
vulgarisation on est c'est devenu un
terme en france pour pour parler de face
au grand public mais d'une façon
générale je pense que il faut toujours
voir tu as toujours un public et qui est
définie tu vois la personne que tu as en
face de toi ou pour le laquelle tu écrit
un bouquin
bah voilà ça peut être effectivement du
grand public ou la sava etre de la
vulgarisation grand public mais tu peux
faire pour moi c'est de la vulgarisation
de faire de la vulgarisation pour des
gens qui sont quand même un peu bon en
sciences ou pas effrayé en tout cas tu
vois effectivement ce moment avec
l'insouciance artificielle qui ont été
plus utilisé par plusieurs scientifiques
dans différents domaines
je pense qu'il a vraiment besoin de son
milieu gare isation complètement
complètement mais parfois règne dans les
équipes donc là effectivement l'ia quand
tu te dis il ya plein de domaines
différents qui vont se retrouver à
devoir finale parler de la même chose
c'est clair qu'il ya besoin il ya besoin
de vulgarisation il a besoin que tout le
monde apprenne un langage commun tu vois
et et parle un peu qu'on prenne en tout
cas eu un truc comme un quoi très
clairement non mais souvent tu vois on a
ces discussions j'ai cette discussion à
la maison et on se dit la vulgarisation
c'est dans nos vies de tous les jours tu
vois même même dans un couple au final
la vulgarisation
c'est dire ce que tu penses vulgariser
en fait c'est c'est dire ce que tu
penses adapté par rapport à la personne
que tu as en face de toi tu parles à un
enfant tu vas à vulgariser tu parles tu
parles à ton partenaire tu vas
vulgariser tu vulgaris que tu ressens tu
vois tu utilises pas forcément témoin à
toi tu utilisé les mots que la personne
en face va comprendre
du coup je pense qu une vulgarisation
c'est c'est ça et après effectivement
ouais t'as des différents types de
public mais en france c'est devenu un
mot pour le grand public en général mais
c'est pas forcément juste à quoi parce
que je pense que c'est pas le cas en
anglais enfin d'anglet ouais tu dis
popularisation du design de
communication
aussi est ce qui est beaucoup en france
le fait de dire comme communication
c'est mal vu
moi je te définit comme communicatrice
scientifique a complètement mais
complètement parce qu en fait ben moi
j'ai commencé ma carrière de communes in
fine ce communicateur communicatrice
scientifique en angleterre tu vois et en
angleterre
ben je suis communicatrice scientifique
c'est à dire que et ça veut ça englobe
plein de choses c'est à dire tu peux
faire des formations aux chercheurs pour
leur expliquer comment communiquer tu
peux toi faire de la communication
scientifique face à un bloc vraiment
plein de choses mais en france on a ce
mot communication qui est hyper mal vu
c'est qu'il est trop en mode shiny tient
là la communication c'est un truc trop
plein de paillettes machin du coup on
utilise culture scientifique culture
scientifique technique et industrielle
etc
mais en fait partout ailleurs aux
designs comme communication et donc ça
ça englobe bas du public engadget de la
popularisation tout quoi ces enveloppes
vraiment tout
mais c'est vrai qu'on dit bassahi comme
sarens communication parce que ça marié
une fois j'étais invité a trick de une
conférence à donner une conférence un
truc de chez les assureurs et bref je
demande comment me présenter ouais et
moi sur ma page linkedin yakhine ce
communiqué tort à la et ils m'ont
présenté en tant que rester en france
est monté en tant que sainz
communicateur il n'osait pas le traduire
en bas mais pourtant c'est ça moi tu
vois je dis que je suis une
communicatrice scientifique freelens
donc là les gens me regardent avec des
yeux au cerveau genre mais qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait quoi mais
effectivement moi j'ai tu dis ça parce
que pendant 2 watts pendant quatre ans
j'ai fait de la beauce et donc j'étais
chercheuse et communicatrice
scientifique tu vois et du coup c'est le
truc qui je me sens pas je sais pas je
sais pas comment je pourrais dire en
français
sinon ouais ouais y'a ya pas de chance
de voir de jeunes souvent mon titre en
fonction de mes humeurs ce que je sais
pas trop je dirais quoi vulgarisateur du
coup ça dépend des joueurs parce que je
suis vulgarisateur médiateur
communicateur mines a aucun qui me plaît
bravo parce que le truc c'est que
vulgarisateur ça veut dire du coup que
c'est toi qui fais de la vulgarisation
tu vois c'est pas forcément des gens que
tu formes donc sinon c'est formateur en
communication scientifique médiateur
c'est une autre forme de vulgarisation
une tu vois c'est enfin en gros c'était
un peu compliqué c'est pour ça que
communicateur scientifique ou wes sahara
group tout quoi un jour quand caen
accueille les gens me demandent ce que
je fais dans la vie c'est pas trop
comment répondre et ce à plus d'un jour
à l'autre c'est est-ce que alors combien
de temps vous avez pour la réponse c'est
ça la question c'est est-ce que vous
avez du temps oui bon ben alors je vais
vous expliquer
est-ce que ça doit être rapide bon bah
je moi j'ai du mal j'ai eu du mal juste
quand j'ai quitté la recherche a à me
placer je disais ex scientifique et puis
au bout d'un an je me suis dit non je
suis toujours scientifique je suis une
ex chercheuse mais ça met des néo
cerveau tu es là je sais plus je lui en
fait qu'est-ce que je fais comment je me
définis et puis effectivement je suis
arrivé en france et là quand je disais
je fais de la communication scientifique
on me regarde et on ne sait pas non
c'est pas de la com pas si les gars
c'est de la com et et j'étais un peu
choqué par la façon dont communication
au final c'était vraiment mal pris de
dire ça en france marketing très
exactement ça fait côté marketing machin
est ce qui en vrai c'est quand même un
peu du marketing c'est vendre de la
science à voir en faire en sorte que les
gens aient envie d' alors c'est pas
forcément acheter un produit mais c'est
écouter de la science l'ire de la
science tu vends de la science tu fais
pas forcément de profits avec etc
mais c'est du marketing de la science
mais c'est juste que en angleterre ou
dans les pays anglo saxons on est
vachement plus directe avec les termes
on n'a pas peur d'utiliser des termes
qui vont fâcher un peu et puis c'est
surtout que c'est pas des termes qui
fâchent mais en france
en france ça fâche quoi en france tu
française tous les mots d'ordre sont un
peu connoté par ci par là mais
souhaitait rapidement jugé ouais tu
marche sur des oeufs un peu tout en quoi
alors qu on en anglais tu inventes des
mots comme ça les gens s'en foutent
ouais exactement et puis voilà tu te
contentes pratique eu exactement mais
mais c'est vrai qu'en france chaque mot
que tu utilises faut vraiment bien
vérifier surtout on a en a plein de mots
compliqués on a médiateur on est à
machin mais si tu fais pas de la
médiation généralement faut bien
vérifier parce qu'on va dire mais non tu
fais pas de médiation bon fille je suis
perdu voilà ce que je suis
[Rires]
en pratique ça dépend de la motivation
quand ça c'est si ça me fait chier je
suis mathématicien ça s'arrête là
discussion exactement moi et moi pareil
je suis neuroscientifique me posais pas
trop de questions généraux scientifique
voilà mes annoncé c'est compliqué mais
c'est vrai que te définir maintenant je
suis habituée c'est marrant ça fait un
an et demi du coup je suis rentré que je
fais ça donc ça va mais les premiers
mois s'étaient c'était dur c'était à nos
cerveaux quoi vraiment qu'est ce que je
dis comment je le dis qu'est-ce qu'il
faut que j'évite comme mot puis au début
j'étais perdu
donc j'étais hyper ancré dans la dans la
communication scientifique mais tu vois
la médiation vulgarisation on est tous
les termes différents mais je disais
tout le temps que tu communication
scientifique
au début je suis même arrivé je sais
même pas ce que ça veut dire csti ce que
ça voulait dire mais qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce que ça veut dire je comprends
pas et puis voilà en fait faut
s'habituer il ya des codes mais c'est
vrai qu'au tout début c'était un peu
mais je comprends pas qu est ce qui se
passe comme ça moi je disais public
ngage mountain sights communiqué tu vois
et puis voilà ça passait très bien et
tout le monde disait exactement les
mêmes termes donc est ce que mon moi
quand j'ai dit que youtube heures en
plus ça ça a été très vite lasser alors
est ce que tu dis youtuber pas ce que tu
dis vidéaste ya aussi ces débats là
c'est compliqué compliqué j'avoue il ya
tellement en plus un fantasme autour de
youtube que imagine que tu dises que tu
es communicateur scientifique sa chaîne
youtube heures vim
c'est quand leur vide à sauver la
personne c'est l'attitude tout le monde
les gens ne savent plus que ça a plus
quoi faire ça déclenche le chaos les
gens partent en courant
[Musique]
non mais c'est difficile mais c'est vrai
que c'est encore des meetic on les crée
en fait complètement stone aux cetc
bassa'a que quelques années au final et
puis autant les chargés de communication
dans des instituts c'est encore à peu
près définit maintenant mais c'est vrai
que nous ce qu'on est en train de faire
là c'est c'est un peu freestyle et du
coup bah ouais on crée notre notre titre
notre nom de jobs et tout voilà en
angleterre je sais que je t'ai docteur
en neurosciences ça passait bien là
depuis que j'ai 20 ans et demi j'ai
quasiment plus demo docteur tu vas en
france ça passe pas aussi bien on va me
dire ah bon j'ai mal à la tête je
devrais prendre quoi là tu fais dr
d'épilepsie ça fait un peu exact
docteur en épilepsie les gens te disent
du kouamé ma soeur est épileptique
alors attendez les gars moi je travaille
sur des rats donc je peux je peut vous
ouvrir je peux vous injectez n'ont pas
injecté vous implanter des électrodes
qui vont du coup enregistré votre
activité cérébrale
sauf que je vais rasé dégueulasse et je
vais go lui et ça sur votre crâne donc
c'est pas super bien fait parce que je
suis pas habitué à travailler sur des
humains mais après vous expliquer quels
médicaments etc etc je sache je sais pas
tu vois mais c'est vrai que les gens
sont surpris et puis c'est pareil ce qui
est drôle aussi c'est que les gens
pensent qu'un chercheur et ça s'est
beaucoup beaucoup due aux films aux
séries et c'est qu'un chercheur qu'un
scientifique va tout savoir sur tout
c'est pas si tu as tu as déjà eu ça je
pense que je peux je comprends les
mathématiques non mais voilà alors que
le truc d'un chercheur c'est juste de
dire non mais en vrai je connais un tout
petit morceau d'un tout petit sujet mais
me posais pas de questions trop trop
large sur un truc quoi tu vois quand j
étais je faisais de la neurologie on
disait ah d'accord mais du coup me poser
des questions sur pas mal parkinson
alzheimer mais tu vois des trucs assez
précis et heureusement le labo de test
dans lequel j'étais on a travaillé sur
toutes ces maladies donc du coup je
connaissais un peu tu vas mai mais je
leur disais mais même les épilepsies je
travaille que sur un type d'épilepsie y
en a plein je suis pas spécialiste du
tout tu vois et ça c'est drôle parce que
souvent dans les séries tu vois ta
docteur en machin genre big bang theory
et non mais ouais big bang theory
m'énerve les gars ils sont là ils
parlent de physique de chimie d'astro de
bio tu leur dis mais non c'est pas
possible ça ça donne une vision
du chercheur ou du scientifique au grand
public est folle quoi genre c'est en
gros la grosse tête qui sait tout qui
sait répondre à toutes les questions sur
tout alors qu'en fait c'est pas ça du
tout du tout du tout quoi ouais mais
pour ça je me fais un peu la remarque
que fallait des gens qui sont invités
solutions sur les plateaux télé il parle
avec une telle assurance en eux mêmes
enfin se dresse ses patients des
chercheurs et du coup ça peut donner
l'impression au grand public voilà un
savant c'est ouais c'est tout ouais même
exactement et puis généralement aussi ce
qui est difficile c'est que le public a
été mis en contact avec généralement des
experts dans leur domaine
donc quand dix experts ça veut dire des
vieux des gens qui travaillent sur aussi
un domaine quand tu es en thèse ou un
post doc c'est quand même très très
centré sur un truc vraiment spécifique
et c'est vrai que après quand tu es à
ton équipe que tu travailles tu vois
quand tu es un chercheur beaucoup plus
seniors généralement tu as grandi aussi
des connaissances tu vois donc ils sont
habitués aux grands experts qui
effectivement en confiance en eux
connaissent un peu tout surtout sur le
sujet et du coup quand tu leur dis mais
ça c'est seulement après 40 ans quoi de
2,2 carrière là quand tu es en thèse je
sais pas tout quoi tu vois quand j'ai
fait ma tête souvent des as mais tu fais
une thèse en euros tu sais tout sur ça
et tu fais mais non les gars n'ont pas
du tout quoi là j'essaye de lire tous
les articles déjà sur les épilepsies
génétiques quand je réussis à tout
retenir
je soutiendrai voilà et leur reste à
côté je n'aurais pas forcément tous tout
en tête kouame mais c'est pour ça je
pense mais c'est aussi ce que je te
disais ou tout début de l'interview on
rencontre très peu de chercheurs dans
notre vie au final c'est vrai donc la
pire en cause du coup d'avoir des trucs
comme fight of sound qui essaient de de
montrer au moins chercheurs pas mal de
gens et merci ça fait plaisir j'ai un
grand sourire mais c'est vrai qu'en fait
j'ai vraiment eu deux énormes motivation
pour développer par 900 et il ya
vraiment eu cette frustration tue c'est
de travailler d'être chercheur et puis
deux quand tu rencontres des gens qui
sont pas en cherche qu il te demande ce
que tu fais tu leur dise je suis
chercheur ou tel truc ou chercheuse un
tel truc et qui disent ouais me raconte
pas ce que tu sur ce ce que tu fais ou
sur les sujets sur lesquels tu
travailles ça doit être trop compliqué
je vais pas comprendre
et là tu sais qui tu directement qu'ils
veulent même pas que tu essayes quoi et
voilà c'est une énorme frustration et
surtout voilà de se dire la science je
pense que là on a besoin de plus de
contacts directs mais ça c'est vraiment
les deux trucs qui m'ont motivé de se
dire que les chercheurs devraient
pouvoir parler au public et puis le
public devrait se rendre compte que
voilà un chercheur c'est pas forcément
quelqu'un avec une blouse blanche des
grosses lunettes des cheveux gris et un
avocat bullaires incompréhensible ça
peut être des jeunes ça peut être des
femmes ça peut être un peu n'importe qui
et ça peut être surtout les gens très
accessible qui sont capables de leur
expliquer leurs recherches
ça m'est arrivé une fois que je disais à
quelqu'un j'estime mathématicien elle va
dit non mais t'es pas mieux non mais
métros mais moi j'ai eu la même chose
souvent en thèse ou même en post doc on
me disait non mais t'as pas une tête de
deux chercheuses quoi et là je les
regarde et je leur dise ah ouais désolé
j'ai oublié mes lunettes et mes besoins
c'est ma réponse mais ça c'était un truc
je le prenais mes régulièrement quoi al
kazim ans à chaque soirée où j'allais où
il n'y avait pas où me demandais ce que
je faisais j'allais rencontrer de
nouvelles personnes
j'avais le droit à tursan pas
à une chercheuse quoi il y avait ma tête
je ne suis pas impressionné par ce que
tu viens de dire ça m'énerve mais à
chaque fois effectivement je te la bomba
désolé j'ai oublié ma blouse et mes
lunettes au labo près mieux la prochaine
fois mais ces dingos parce que dans le
dans la tête des gens c'est
effectivement un chercheur ou une
chercheuse c'est une personne vieille
quoi personne qui est un peu chiante un
peu chiante pas trop capable de
s'exprimer super inaccessible qui
bafouille des trucs que personne ne
comprend si possible avec des grosses
lunettes fond de bouteille
et puis ouais pas super pas forcément
physiquement sympa tu vois genre des
gens un peu repoussant
on m'a déjà dit on m'a dit un truc que
j'ai qui alors je pense était un
compliment mais qui moi m'a rendu mes
sur colère c'était de me dire c'est trop
jolie pour te gâcher dans un labo je
t'emmerde
c'est du langage cru mais ça m'a énervé
en fait ben pourquoi fin je me gâche pas
déjà je pourrais tu as déjà considérer
que c'est me gâcher dans un labo c'est
hyper sexy c'est quoi tu préférais
mettre en vitrine
enfin déjà je suis pas je suis pas une
mannequin clairement voilà et puis ça
veut dire quoi te gâcher dans un labo
toi tu dégages dans un bureau tous les
jours on considère pas que c'est gâcher
tu vois et ça c'est une des réflexions
qui m'avait mise hors de moi je m'étais
dit je pense qu'en plus le gars il a
essayé de faire un compliment mais du
coup il est ce compliment il est limite
un peu sexiste
il est limite vraiment pas très cool
pour les chercheurs et puis en quoi tu
vois faire de la recherche c'est se
cacher dans un labo c'est pas mal quand
même comment mark gallagher pas un
panneau depuis l'entrée du labo interdit
aux jolies filles
non mais ça c'est un truc de fou quoi et
puis surtout enfin où tu sais des potes
à moi qui découvrait mes copines
chercheuse et qui me disait ah mais je
pensais pas que d'aider des filles
attractif tu vois enfin jolie pouvait
pouvait faire de la recherche
mais c'est à dire quoi c'est à dire que
la bourse de thèse elle est donnée par
rapport au physique tu vois alors elle
est employée dans les films beaucoup de
clichés de mary du scientifique heures
déjà mecque et c'est complètement
complètement bat souvent tu vois genre
mais big bang theory c'est encore le
truc de référence mais tu vois la
neuroscientifique baleine scientifique
est pas gâté quoi
[Rires]
et voilà ce qui est dommage parce que
bien sûr la bimbo c'est la nana stupide
la blonde bimbo c'est la nana stupide un
petit peu et la neuroscientifique passé
la moche quoi fâcher
je suis fâché d'identité ou pas elle
mais non mais qui ressemble au patron je
suis heureux scientifique on faisait
comme dans big bang theory way génial
j'aurais préféré que tu me dises comme
dans grey's anatomy tu vois il ya des
neuro bon après sont ils sont docteurs
je suis pas docteur effectivement laissé
règles bang theory quand même alors
autant je trouve que la série est cool
mais je trouve quand en images du
chercheur et en idées reçues sur le
chercheur bâle a quand même contribué à
avoir un bon paquet d'aidés reçues à la
fois sur le physique à la fois sur les
connaissances enfin tu vois c'est ce qui
est dommage parce que c'est une série
cool mais au début je les boycotter à
cause de ce à quoi j'ai regardé quelques
épisodes et je me suis dit mais non mais
c'est juste pas possible tu peux pas
représenter ça comme ça tu vois après il
ya les experts ou là c'est pareil tu te
dis hein
un échantillon des dns que c'est le père
tu n'es dans une machine
une heure après tu sais tu dis moi je
suis généticienne est à peu près
plusieurs jours tu vois pour arriver à
la même conclusion et du coup simon chef
regarde les experts ce soir il va me
demander les résultats de manip trop tôt
il va crois que ça se passe comme ça
parce que les chercheurs oublie comment
ça se passe dans les labos généralement
et le temps que met les manies prennent
donc mai
meiway big bang theory chez sjs c'est
voilà c'est une série cool mais pas mal
de clichés
ouais ouais je pense qu'ils ont été
vraiment de ce vraiment dans le cliché
au début quand on pense qu'au fur et à
mesure des saisons chercher à être un
peu plus petit peu plus cool avec les
scientifiques mais ouais mais du coup il
ya plein de gens qu'ils prennent aussi
premier degré tu vois aussi m
donc voilà mais c'est pas grave
un jour on fera un big bang theory
version version nous c'est à dire non
friends de quoi ah bah oui exact j'ai
choisi de mettre le lien la photo
quelque part aux décisions de cette
vidéo avec le live de string theory de
cette école ouais non c'était c'était
vraiment très très cool très très cool
ouais
et est ce que tu as d'autres questions
ça fait donc quoi tu disais que tu avais
quelques km en vtt freelens et que tu
avais d'autres faits d'autres projets en
dehors de 100 web ouais ouais
alors bon en ce moment on peut dire que
j'ai ma vie tourne un peu autour de
penneteau cents mais j'ai pas mal de
trucs différents qui vont alors je
travaille avec hindawi qui est une
maison de publication
qui au débat a été créé en egypte je
crois mais au final maintenant il ya les
bureaux à londres et
c'est un put donc c'est publishers' open
access eux depuis depuis très longtemps
et du coup l'idée c'est que ils ont
envie pas seulement de faire de l'open
access ils ont vraiment envie de
partager la science et d'être actif en
communication scientifique
donc du coup on est en train d'essayer
de monter une plate-forme pour pour
avoir pas mal d'articles de culture de
communication scientifique mais à la
fois destination des chercheurs à
destination des professionnels de la
culture scientifique et c'est que ce
soit tu vois un guide sur les bonnes
pratiques que ce soit des articles sur
des initiatives qui se passe déjà et
c'est donc ça je développe ça avec eux
donc ça c'était mon réseau de londres tu
vois typiquement que je développe donc
ça me fait ça me fait bien kiffé je
travaille avec haddock talent management
pour donner des formations aux étudiants
en thèse aux doctorants généralement ces
déformations sur leur projet doctorale
sur comment bien gérer en gros leur
thèse comment gérer l'après thèse et
sait comment gérer leurs réseaux tu vois
donc
là par exemple hier et aujourd'hui c'est
ce que je faisais je fais ça quasi toute
la semaine prochaine ce qui est pas mal
du tout parce que souvent tu vois je me
dis que nous quand on était en tête
enfin moi en tout cas petit dinosaure
quand j'étais en thèse j'ai soutenu ma
thèse
il ya dix ans un chat quand même à a
rappelé un peu les faits je me sens
vieille et ça va ouais ça va ça va mais
quand même un peu
et du coup tu vas nous à l'époque quand
j'étais en tête
c'est vrai que la seule option pour
après c'était faire un post doc et puis
est chercheurs ou enseignants chercheurs
et il n'y avait pas beaucoup plus de job
que maintenant c'est juste qu'on était
super mal informés et du coup j'ai vu
plein plein plein de potes en post doc
autour de moi finalement tu vois échouer
son post docs ou pas avoir autant de
résultats qui l'attendait ou de
publications qui l'attendait ou quelle
qu'elle attendait et du coup se
retrouver complètement démuni après six
ans de post doc généralement après la
thèse et c'est à dire qu'est ce que je
fais et là c'est le premier moment où il
se mettait à y réfléchir
et du coup c'est j'aime bien ces
formations donner ce genre de formation
pour un petit peu donner des outils aux
doctorants de maintenant et leur dire
voilà votre projet votre projet de
carrière il se décide pas seulement une
fois que vous avez fait de post doc et
vous savez plus quoi faire s'est il faut
être acteur du projet maintenant et voir
si vous voulez faire ça si vous voulez
faire un post doc partir dans le privé
faire un autre boulot parce qu'il ya de
plus en plus de choses qui sont ouvertes
aux doctorants en fait donc voilà c'est
ce genre de formation parfois je
travaille avec une boîte de com qui
s'appelle agents majeur aussi sur donc
sur des formations plutôt la
communication donc ça va de trucs
comment pitch et à ma grande spécialité
c'est aussi les réseaux sociaux pour les
chercheurs donc en gros apprendre
apprendre à bien twitté parce que il ya
beaucoup plus de
ii ya énormément de scientifiques sur
twitter et en a de plus en plus chaque
jour en fait et on sait pas forcément
toujours bien twitté comment utiliser
twitter comment s'en servir pour la
recherche
et c'est donc donc ça et puis je
travaille aussi avec certains instituts
sur le développement là par exemple je
travaille à christian clôt sur chez
adaptation pour développer une stratégie
sur ces réseaux sociaux
donc en gros parlait de la science
parler de ce qu'ils font sur les réseaux
sociaux
donc en fait j'ai vraiment tu vas deux
gros spécialité il y en a une ça va être
le réseau de communications
scientifiques réseaux sociaux etc et
l'autre ça va être formation en com ou
en projet gestion de projet et c'est
juste revenir sur le rebond d'hier sur
le sur les conseils de carrière et que
tu donnes doctorant es ce que tu as
entendu parler d'eux et qui sonna wars
non c'est un site web
blog qui fait aussi des podcasts qui
s'intéressent à comment avoir enfin ses
conseils de carrière en fait pour avoir
des carrières qui sont à haut impact à
génial notamment dans une perspective
d'altruisme et efficace c'est d'avoir un
maximum normal donc voilà ça ça pourrait
être peut-être intéressé mais carrément
super intéressant merci faut mettre le
lien aussi du coup je voudrais le lire
top carrément ma j'irai voir ça et
d'ailleurs je suis donnerait bientôt en
plus une formation une introduction à ce
genre d'idées dans une université
bientôt d'accord une fois aussi tu fais
des formations or c'est ce n'est pas
tellement faux papiers pour faire ça
c'est ce pays dans le cadre de la 13ème
efficace ouais mais moi je pense que
c'est des idées importantes parce que
lorsqu'on surtout parce qu'on est bon
élève en forme en tout cas j'étais bon
élève du coup je suis je suis le chemin
qu'on compte là si je me suis jamais dit
pas forcément pris le temps de me poser
la question de quelle carrière foudre
est vraiment à voir et en particulier à
celles à voir ses perspectives question
des impacts que je peux avoir c'est
évident et des carrières voilà
typiquement si on est directrice
internationale comme ça rayonne à
l'international que carmaux bénéfique
ouais mais c'est vrai que c'est des
trucs enfin moi je les fais par passion
est vraiment pas par tu vois pas par
comment dire calcul ou quoi c'est juste
que j'avais envie que par hind scène
soit partout et du coup bah on m'a
proposé ça j'ai dit oui quoi et
maintenant c'est plus j'ai un calcul
strates mais la strate c'est vraiment la
strate par rapport à il faut qu'on se
développe dans des pays où c'est plus
compliqué il faut que la science soit
accessible à tout le monde et c'est donc
mais c'est c'est un peu de l'altruisme
si tu vois dans le sens là où j'ai
vraiment envie que voilà les gens
bénéficient de ce qui se passe autour de
chez eux et que je passais déjà entendu
parler de l'altruisme efficace j'en ai
entendu parler mais j'ai pas creuser je
vais le faire valider ses justes
l'altruisme mais qui a au impact essaie
de faire les actions bénéfiques et
justement il ya une discussion très
régulière sur les pays en voie de
développement
je pense qu'il faut encore il appelait
comme ça mais en gros les bâtiments les
pays d'afrique ou parce qu'ils ont un
potentiel de développement
l'amélioration 1 $ chez heures au plan
beaucoup plus qu'un dollar en suisse
étaient bons et que du coup concentrer
les efforts en afrique ah c'est ça qui
est le plus d'impact 10 microns bah oui
non mais voilà et du couffin et puis
surtout il se passe plein de choses fin
tu vois c'est peut-être des pays qui ont
un développement qui est différent qui
est peut-être un petit peu moins
importants que les nôtres mais ils font
tellement de choses c'est ce et c'est
ces tops de participer à ce
développement justement je pense mais
c'est la même chose aussi tu vois et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas non plus
délaissé la france c'est pour ça que tu
vas en termes de développement de
penneteau scène j'ai envie aussi qu'on
aille un peu partout en france
parce que c'est bien de dire tiens on va
aider dans d'autres pays etc
mais il faut aussi s'occuper du sien
d'abord et
typiquement aller dans plein de village
tu as pour la fête de la science je suis
allé donner un une présentation à
lannemezan à côté de toulouse
ok donc je ne sais plus quel département
c'est là j'ai un gros truc mais en gros
juste à côté de toulouse et du coup
j'étais dans une dans une salle dans un
tout petit village dans las dans l'amphi
de cinéma de l'hôpital tu vas il avait
25 personnes en face de moi et j'ai
expliqué un petit peu j'ai parlé du
cerveau j'ai expliqué les bases sur le
cerveau et j'étais super contente parce
que voilà les gens s'excusait me
disaient les organisateurs me disait on
est vraiment désolé il n'y a pas
beaucoup de monde et tout mais je leur
disais mais je préfère parler devant
vincent personnes dans un village que
devant 300 personnes à paris au final
parce que paris on est tellement exposé
à plein d'événements il ya tellement de
possibilités ces gens là ces 25
personnes là-bas au final c'était
c'était des gens qui se sont déplacés et
des gens qui ont pas des milliers
d'événements de sciences autour de quoi
donc donc
donc voilà et du coup quand tu dois
encore des points qui donnent des
présentations dont on parle tant que 50
cent giral où je lis fait non alors non
je le fais plus je les fais plusieurs
fois je les fais une fois sur
l'épilepsie
normal quand j'étais en post doc parce
qu'en fait
j'ai organisé une soirée spéciale
épilepsie puis je me suis dit mais tiens
pourquoi je ferais pas l'intro sur
l'épilepsie tu vois vu que bah c'est un
peu mon domaine au final j'avais jamais
fait pas une taupe scène je me suis dis
pas peut-être que je vais en faire quand
même j'en ai fait il ya donc en 2018 sur
l'ocytocine je sais pas ça te parle
c'est la molécule du contact humain dans
un genre doigt la fatigue
alors elle est connue pour plein de
choses mais c'est l'hormone de donc ça
généralement appelée l'hormone ou
molécules de l'amour de la fidélité de
la tâche etc
c'est en gros ton cerveau produit un pic
de sites hocine pendant plein de choses
par exemple après
des rapports sexuels donc pour favoriser
l'attachement la femme qui accouche
généralement il ya un gros pic de sites
aussi donc ça permet de se lier aux
nourrissons ça permet aussi généralement
le pic de lactation et la lactation va
être induite par l'ocytocine et moi j'ai
parlé du campagnol parce que en fait il
ya deux types de campagnols il ya le
campagnol des prix et le campagnol des
ratons yaël le campagnol des montagnes
et le campagnol deschamps je crois est
en gros le campagnol des chances et le
campagnol fidèles et l'autre campagnols
c'est le co pagnol infidèle et en fait
il ya des chercheurs qui ont vu que
après accouplement les campagnols qui
était fidèle il y avait des gros pic
d'oxytocine dans leur cerveau et les
campagnols infidèle eux par contre pas
de pic d'oxytocine et si tu prenais les
campagnols fidèles et que tu bloqué
l'oxytocine dans leur cerveau et que du
coup ils veulent et ils deviennent un
fidèle ils deviennent des campagnes et
l'infidèle donc je trouvais ça assez
fantastique on a fait une soirée sur la
neurobiologie de l'amour du coup du coup
forcément tu vois le campagnol j'avais
trop envie d'en parler donc donc j'ai
fait j'ai fait une petite petite
présentation là dessus ce qui est pas du
tout des recherches que j'ai fait mais
j'avais déjà fait plusieurs fois deux
impacts of thrones là dessus j'ai fait
une vidéo avec un pote qui faisait des
vidéos youtube de vulgarisation
scientifique à londres où j'ai dû
modéliser le campagnol donc lui
expliquer la science et moi à côté je
faisais le campagnol qui se faisait
injecter des trucs et pour la petite
anecdote d'ailleurs on s'est fait il ya
des gens on était dans le
dans le square du labo qui était dans un
hôpital est en fait il ya des gens qui
sont venus nous demander si on était de
l'hôpital psychiatrique parce qu'on
était on est elle entrain moi j'étais en
train de faire la campagne hall avec une
blouse lui il était à côté venez y là il
n'avait pas vu qu'il y avait une caméra
et en fait on me met des campagnols qui
se faisait des câlins et du coup on se
mettait côte à côte et on se frottait le
bras et là ils viennent nous voir et
nous disent il nous demande si tout va
bien et tout il ya un moment ils nous
ont dit mais vous êtes de sortie là on
dit mais de sortie doux mais de l'oca
talent est là on s'est regardés au delà
non mais vous n'êtes pas sérieux les
gars on est violent je suis docteur non
alors à dix mais en fait les nullités en
thèse à l'époque on essaie lui c'est
c'est un doctorant et moi je travaille à
l'institut of neurology tu vas et du
coup ils nous ont regardés stella ok
mais tu sais ils sont partis s'est dit
pas convaincu plastique c'est un moment
magnifique de m tu vois où je me suis
fait prendre par une nana moitié échappé
de l'hôpital psychiatrique mais mais du
coup c'est vrai que voilà ce sujet de
campagnols je l'avais tour et ça assez
intéressant et puis c'est une façon de
parler de recherche sur le cerveau qui
sont qui sont intéressants quoi tu vois
surtout que c est aussitôt sint en
entend parler partout il avait fait une
manie possible sur les gens parce que
maintenant on vend de desprès
d'oxytocine pour donner de la confiance
en soi pour permettre éventuellement un
lien plus facile et tout est du coup
j'avais fait il y avait la moitié de la
salle qui c'était
tchité avec de l'eau et l'autre qui
s'étaient quittées avec de l'occitan sin
et on avait essayé de voir si les
relations entre les gens étaient
différents pendant la soirée je les fais
plusieurs fois cette expérience est allé
à chaque fois ça ne donne rien tristesse
donc généralement je fini par leur dire
bon bah voilà vous avez vécu une
expérience scientifique donc un échec
l'avis de scientifiques c'est
généralement répliqué ce genre de trucs
donc ce genre d'échec c'était même pas
grave si ça marchait pas c'est normal et
non le site hocine généralement c'est
dans le cerveau est comme je t'ai dit
alors tu sais le cerveau tap les choses
se passent pas forcément il ya une
grosse barrière qui filtrent le sang qui
filtre tout avant de laisser passer à
l'intérieur donc probablement si on
injectait des gens avec de l'occitan
sinon ça ferait peut-être quelque chose
mais j'ai pas le droit de le faire
directement dans le cerveau des plus bas
oui ce serait cool dont tu vas faire un
penneteau sayen ces injections cerveau
activement tuner costumes battus miner
ce que s'attache à les combattre mais
mais bizarrement on me laisse pas faire
ça encore tu vois on m'a pas autorisé à
faire un pas 900 spéciale je vous
injecte des trucs dans le cerveau je
trouve ça un peu réducteur ça dommage
mais bon c'est pas grave on fait ça
viendra patience patience
mais je pense qu'il y aura mais oui ou
alors quand il y aura une intelligence
artificielle qui ça a tellement proches
du cerveau de l'homme tu vois peut-être
capable de réagir avec des molécules
chimiques ambiante et doux que là du
coup en injectera info cerveau offert à
ou les vrais dit qu ils font tu m'as dit
que je pouvais parler autant que je
voulais donc ce sera coupée peut-être
c'est pas grave tant pis j'essaie non
mais c'est surtout il ya des chercheurs
qui bossent sur des organes aux ide je
sais pas si tu as déjà entendu parler de
ça c'est des mini cerveau dans des dans
des boîtes de pétri donc on sait déjà
faire vivre des neurones dans des bois
dans des boîtes en plastique mais des
organes aux ide c'est vraiment essayé de
refabriquer des mini cerveau donc mais
de combien de neurones b de neurones
mais c'est pas que les neurones c'est tu
mets les neurones tu mets du coup les
cellules gliales c'est les baby-sitters
des neurones là tu mets ça tu essaies de
l'est vascularisé et c'est pour créer
des petites boules et notamment il ya
une de mes une de mes copines en
angleterre c'est linares appel et qui
travaille à lui ciel institute of
neurology qui eux essayent de faire ça
dans leurs labos et du coup l'idée ce
serait d'avoir des mini cerveau en boîte
de pétri et d'être pas forcément obligé
d'utiliser des
des animaux et de pouvoir déjà dans des
boîtes de pétri tu vois utiliser
analyser des phénomènes qui qui
demanderait plus que juste les neurones
parce qu'en fait quand tu fais de la
neuro ce qui est compliqué c'est quand
tu as tes cellule en boîte de pétri
c'est généralement super purifier le
milieu il est il est super super pur il
est super contrôler et le nombre de
cellules que tu ailles a généralement
pas les vaisseaux sanguins il n'y a pas
toutes les cellules tu vois tu
sélectionnes un type de cellule
donc du coup au final tu vois ce qui se
passe mais c'est rarement ce qui se
passe dans la vraie vie tu vois dans un
vrai cerveau donc plus tu arrives à
faire des morceaux de cerveau connecter
avec plein de choses plus du coup tu vas
te rapprocher d'une analyse in vitro
d'un truc qui se passe vraiment quoi
l'étude tu connais le vbl bone's project
yes tu as été des collaborations n'ont
pas trop pop même pas du tout d'ailleurs
je
ouais moi j'étais de ses plus en
thérapie génique déjà je développais
mais virus jeu machin donc j'ai pas trop
eu de ça mais non c'est juste le gros
projet de le pfl mais l'acquis ça c'est
fait c'est alors que tu peux cacher la
case ça c'est fait c'est bon ça ça ne
sera pas coupée au montage par contre tu
as d'autres choses à rajouter pas écoute
je crois que j'ai quand même pas mal
raconté ma vie là bas c'est bête hein
ouais ouais ouais non j'ai pas grand
chose à rajouter je crois que j'ai ouais
j'ai dit tout ce que je voulais dire
jeter couper la parole plein de fois
donc ouais j'ai l'impression que j'ai
fait j'ai juste ou des fêtes avait comme
chez toi s'agit exactement tu m'a dit
fais comme chez toi
pas de problème je me suis installé j'ai
le chat juste à côté de moi tu vois
j'avais ma théière de tai chi est parti
dans la discussion
bref juste pour les auditeurs ont fait
ça sur skype
quand même quand il le dit dis ça l est
pas vraiment chez moi chez moi celui-ci
a ramené son chien exactement je suis
chez moi dooya plume que malheureusement
personne n'a pu voir qu'il n'ya pas
l'oeil à plumes à côté qui vérifie bien
que je raconte pas de bêtises
et puis il ya la théière de tai chi est
l'élément indispensable à ma survie
travers du coup j'ai deux dernières
questions pour finir est ce votre cas
c'est l'avant dernière question c'est
quel message clé que tu aimerais que les
auditeurs retiennent de tout de tout ce
que j'ai racontée bref de tout ce que tu
as raconté
alors j'aimerais que est ce que j'ai le
droit d'en faire deux parce que on m'a
collé en communication qu'il fallait
cibler son audience suivant mon audience
j'en ai deux aux scientifiques qui
m'écoutent
j'ai envie de leur dire que si vous
faites de la vulgarisation c'est top
si vous en faites pas et si ça vous
intéresse franchement hésitez pas à
sauter le pas renseignez-vous autour de
vous il ya pleins pleins d'initiatives
et
et je pense que ça ne peut que vous
aider dans votre carrière de
scientifique ou de chercheurs et
chercheuses donc vraiment c'est une
bonne chose à faire et au grand public
qui écouterait déjà merci d'écouter ça
veut dire que vous intéressez un petit
peu à la science et puis voilà la
science c'est pas si compliqué que ça en
a l'air
et il ya plein de gens qui travaillent à
essayer de la vulgariser et de voulu
apporter sur un plateau d'une façon
assez digest dont toile et d'ailleurs
bravo pour ce que tu fais est donc merci
aux gens qui écoutent et
et continuer de voilà de vous informer
de science essayez aussi de deux
peut-être faire passer le mot autour de
vous pour des gens qui seraient pas
forcément intéressés par la science ou
scientifique que la science c'est pas
forcément compliqué c'est pas forcément
inaccessible et qu' il ya plein de
formes de vulgarisation et que et qu' il
ya forcément une forme qui vous convient
que ce soit des vidéos des bd des taux
qu'en live des blogs plein plein de
choses des podcasts voilà faut faut
regarder il ya forcément à une forme de
vulgarisation qui vous attire
j'aurais été aussi un message c'est que
a priori en ce moment les moments la
diffusion de ce podcast les billets de
bateau sera de passage seront en vente
ah oui alors tu vois j'étais même pas
parti sur de la promo mais oui
effectivement les tickets sont sont
disponibles sur le site web comme on est
une associée des tickets à 2 euros
donc pour nous aider à fonctionner si
vous avez écouté jusqu'ici vous savez
pourquoi
le site s'est pas 900 point fr et si on
est dans 54 villes en france cette année
donc vraiment dans plein plein plein
d'endroits et vous n'avez pas d' excuses
si vous n'êtes pas en france il ya
vingt-trois autres pays un peu partout
dans le monde qui ont pas une tôle signs
les dates c'est du 20 au 22 mai donc
donc voilà il ya forcément une soirée
payne cent près de chez vous que vous
soyez en france ou ailleurs
super est bon pour mais pour ceux qui
veulent me voir particules serait moi je
vais à paris le 20 mai oui alors
j'espère jusqu'au moment où ce podcast
sera en ligne les billets ne seront pas
complet parce que paris généralement
c'est la bataille
les événements sont complets en quelques
jours voire quelques heures pour les
plus pour les les plus
moi elle est plus famous quoi ceux qui
ont plus de succès donc s'il reste
encore des tickets n'hésitez pas à les
voir mais voilà il ya plein d'autres
soirées mais effectivement on a la
chance d'avoir les à paris cette année
et je suis trop contente je t'ai vu sur
le programme j'avoue je me tiens on va
trop bien parce que c'est pas moi qui
gère le programme donc parfois je
découvre et je vois des gens que j'aime
bien d'aider des potes à moi et à pâtit
un top bompas super j'ai même pas eu à
forcer les gens c'est celle assez petit
petit dernier petit commentaire au début
c'était drôle parce que c'est vrai que
ça a joué pas mal sur mon réseau la
première année ou deux potes de poste ou
de gens que je connaissais de nom
souvent dans la liste des gens qui
venaient dans la liste des intervenants
c'était des gens que je connaissais de
nom - est là et la maintenance et au
final tu vois toi tu étais là sur le
programme s'est même pas ma faute quoi
j'ai et ça c'est chouette parce que je
vois des gens super bien je vois des
gens que je connais et je me dis mais
c'est même plus j'ai même pu aller
forcer maintenance et mes équipes qui
vont les chercher où même eux qui
viennent directement et et ça fait super
plaisir et puis de voir aussi plein de
gens que je connais pas c'est génial ça
roule tout seul
ouais ça roule tout seul sévère et est
ce que tu pourrais aussi faire de
recommandations de vidéos podcasts
livres ou personnes à suivre
oh là là deux temps que c'est trop ou
c'est pas c'est pas assez alors podcast
bah je vais forcément dire podcast
science parce que je fais partie de
l'équipe même si en ce moment je vous
avouerai c'est à eux que je parle s'il
m'écoute que je suis désolé j'ai pas le
temps vraiment de m'impliquer mais ils
sont géniaux
c'est voilà c'est une équipe comme paint
the sign sein de deux bénévoles de gens
qui travaillent hyper dur pour vous
apporter des sujets super intéressant et
il ya des tonnes d'épisodes sur plein
plein de choses donc voilà un podcast
c'est sûr que je conseillerai podcast
science sinon je vais pas dire toi parce
que bon c'est de la triche en livre le
dernier que j'ai eu dans les mains
j'ai trouvé génial c'est retour vers le
palais au que tata entendra probablement
entendu parler du bouquin tu l'as lu moi
j'ai pas lu je n'ai pas fini de le lire
mais voilà c'est écrit par la team paléo
donc
il y a pierre karner marion sabourdy
mais il ya aussi d'autres gens
et dont je n'ai pas les noms là tout de
suite ou en tout cas j'ai peur de les
écorchés il y en ag les pseudo twitter
mais ça ne va pas marcher mais en
brousse tout une ti vct de co auteur et
l'idée c'est de parler de ce que nos
ancêtres ont inventé bien avant nous le
seul bémol c'est que ça ne parle pas de
chat donc j'espère qu'ils vont faire un
numéro deux avec les chats les matous de
la réalité voilà donc mais c'est dur de
choisir que deux sachant qu'il ya
tellement de gens géniaux et de
d'initiative et de bouquins a conseillé
que voilà c'est dur d'en dire que deux
donc je suis juste dit les deux qui me
venait comme ça tous les autres si j'en
ai pas parlé je suis désolé n'en voulait
pas y'en a que de ça un peu pas partie
du jeu tu es bien c'est bien tu as
raison tu as raison sinon tout le
podcast ce serait juste sur sa donc
ouais bon ouais pour être honnête je
pense que la première respecter la règle
c'est vrai déclic et ça finit pas je
vais garder je vais rester comme ça
parce que sinon sinon plus on y va et
plus je me dire il ya des gens qu'il
faut pas que j'oublie et machins là au
moins tu vois on comptait 102 je me dis
que j'ai pas le choix et que
pas citer tout le monde de toute façon
super bas merci beaucoup beaucoup en
tout cas le dis je pense est super sport
je trouve ça super sympa pour les
auditeurs à bientôt pour une prochaine
fois
probablement